it's not easy to understand that other
people are genuinely different from you
and how they might be different and
maybe even more
difficult is to understand
that the differences although
frustrating are also necessary
it isn't obvious to me that anyone wants
to leave live a meaningless existence
i don't think you can live a meaningless
existence without becoming corrupted
because the pain of existence will
corrupt you without a
saving meaning
and it also seems to me that
you can sell the story that meaning is
to be found in responsibility
when i've tried to sell that story to
myself i seem to buy it and
when i've tried to communicate it with
other people it renders them silent
large crowds of people silent and that's
strange because
i'm not sure why that is
it's perhaps because the connection
between responsibility and meaning had
never been made
for in in that explicitly somehow
because meaning gets
contaminated with happiness or
something like that but it's to be found
in responsibility and then you could say
well there isn't any
any responsibility that's more
compelling than
trying to aid things in the
manifestation
of their divine form
that should be an adventure that could
be sold and i don't know why the church
can't do it
i don't understand that and
because it seems to me that that's
something that i've done at least in
part
and that accounts for
the strange popularity of the biblical
lectures in particular yeah
and
but i've also and i i do believe that i
do believe that that
the right striving is to
attempt with all your heart to
encourage things to develop along that
towards that divine goal like what else
would you possibly do once you think
that through it's like
you're always aiming at something that's
better or you wouldn't be aiming you're
always moving towards something that's
better or you wouldn't be moving so then
why wouldn't you move towards the
greatest good
yeah well it's because it's terrifying i
suppose in part
but then as you know i've tried to put
that into practice in my life and
it's tearing me into pieces
yeah
i asked you to define love and i'm going
to define it on my terms now and that is
the best in me serving the best in you
and i think that's the deepest pleasure
that's the deepest and most lasting
pleasure and it is the most fundamental
fundamental motivation it's the
inexhaustible source because if i can do
that whenever i do that i feel that i'm
being properly
and there's nothing better than that and
you can extend that to you can extend
that to to to to the world to uh
situations places well i think that's
what you're supposed to do by accepting
the proposition that god is love
i mean it's god is love and god is logos
those are those are both there so then
the question to some degree is the rank
order of the two and i would say god is
truth within love
and that's the animating spirit of
mankind and that's a way different claim
than the one the atheists are going
after by the way yeah think about it
everyone is truth is truth in the
service of love not the best animating
spirit of mankind when it isn't pursuing
an aberration we can all ask ourselves
that question i think that's a a good
question to ask
thank you joe what i mean i i think it
it re
i think it reorients us today we can put
that on a t-shirt
is is truth in the service of love a
good question i
i guess i i see them as more i i see
them as more interpenetrating i want to
make a stronger relationship between
them than just a relationship of service
um i mean this is a matter of man yeah
that uh
that
this is why i like the term realization
that love is a way of of affording
realization and it and the deepest
knowing you have of reality is in
realization that's what i if i had to
okay so well so it seems to me okay so
i'll make i'll make an appendage to my
claim right
the reality that is most justifiable is
brought about by the action of truth in
the service of love
yeah but i i guess what i'm saying is i
see truth
i i think you're using it and i've heard
you use true as something beyond a a
correspondence between the semantic
content of a proposition reality i've
heard you talk about yes right right and
we even use that when we when we use the
phrase yes it seems to incorporate some
of those other dimensions that exactly
talking about exactly okay great man so
fill me in well that's what i'm trying
to get at i'm trying to get at that
power is a way of you know when when
your shot is true your skill has been
effective
and and you're going to hit the mark
right but but but presence is also a way
in which things are are true to form
right and
and then care
but the participatory knowing is when
we're like the deepest sense of true
which is you know related to trust and
and being betrothed to the world in an
important way
so if you will allow me to expand what
you mean by true to cover all of those
dimensions betrothed to the world in
that you extend the same courtesy to the
world that you described extending to
your partner exactly i think the the
answer to nihilism isn't some
propositional answer or this is what i
get from nishite yeah right it's to
re-learn and i mean this deeply in the
buddhist sense of sati to remember
what it is to fall in love with reality
to fall in love with being and if that's
what you're saying is the enemy do you
think that's what sam harris is striving
for in his spirituality
well and it's not a it's not a throwaway
answer it's like what's he up to exactly
i mean
he's he's he isn't he on a sofia
um
finally a sofia adventure
i think
everybody is how can i put this
everybody
lives from the
the non-propositional kinds of knowing
emphasized by plato and that's what all
of the scholastic research is pointing
to now that socrates was trying to point
people to the non-propositional knowing
the procedural the perspective of the
participatory i think we all have to
live from that given a lot of things
i've said a lot of things we've said
well you should maybe you could you
could expound on those a bit more for us
and clarify a bit more and
so you said the answer to nihilism
that isn't that isn't exactly a comment
on my comment that the culture war is
about the claim
that the drive to power is at the core
of western being i think that's an
equally nihilistic claim i that's that's
my my point the claim the the claim is
nihilistic or my claim about that is
nihilistic on both that power is a
fundamental reality is an attempt to
assaje the wounding of nihilism but it
is fundamentally mistaken in its
endeavor it will it is it is it is
constituted the wrong way it's like
framing a problem the wrong way so that
yeah you know do not get the insight
needed to get to the solution of the
problem i so i think of it as a
fundamental misframing that's what i'm
trying to say okay that's why that's why
i'm not i'm that's why i'm hesitant to
say either yes or no to it because
i get it yeah well i believe that i
believe that it is misframed because i
don't think it would be taking us in
such a pathological direction the whole
argument exactly if it wasn't miss frame
i've been thinking psychologically again
about
christianity
and i know that christianity is an
extension of
other metaphysical
forms of thought
but
that predated
but it looked to me like and and some of
those were derived from mesopotamia and
some of them were derived from greece
and some of them were derived from
judaism and other sources
but they all seem to me to be
part of the conversation that human
beings have been having amongst
themselves
for thousands of years about what the
nature of the ideal human being is
and now i see these cathedrals these
works of art in architecture that took a
tremendous amount of labor
and produce a dome-like structure that
represents the sky and you see christ as
logos
spread out on the sky as a transcendent
force and you ask yourself well what
exactly is that
signifying and the answer is at least
the proposition of a kind of ideal
that's associated with let's say
universal love and truth in speech
that's the logos
summed up in two phrases and
if there's no
metaphysical reality there at all
there's still this
imaginative enterprise that
characterizes the entire human
what imaginative effort
cultural effort to posit a transcendent
ideal that we would live in relationship
to
and i i just don't see that case being
made very strongly and i can't really
understand why because isn't it rather
obvious that at least part of what
christianity has been is the attempt by
thousands of people over thousands of
years to specify the nature of an ideal
certainly i would say so and i would say
that the fact that
these uh principles
uh actually work is uh proof of their
uh
of the
proof of there being true accounts of
what the nature of the real is um well
let's let's approach this from a couple
of different angles jordan you know the
first is
one of the things that i i profoundly
believe is that
you know these young people seeking you
know deeper answers and you know to
however
much they may be flailing about
you know it's not
their fault
that many perhaps most of the
institutions they will encounter
will betray that which is deepest in
them we'll we'll we'll we'll denigrate
we'll tell them no none of this thing
that none of these things that you're
seeking are really real i mean i think
you know i've been talking uh uh
thinking a lot over the years about
architecture and what is going on in
brutalist architecture and and it really
does seem to me that in brutalist
architecture to live in relation to
brutalist architecture it is as if you
had a parent that said you know you're
nothing
you're nothing you'll never amount to
and of course there are terrible people
terrible to say people actually there
are people in these situations who live
with with such
dysfunctional uh
uh lack of love and antagonism this is
the way that this is the home life that
they that that some people uh terribly
have but i'm using this as an example
because i think what brutalist
architecture does is it declares to the
whole world and to you that you are
there is no truth there is no beauty you
are nothing accept it it's just a
concrete
uh uh uh
annihilating force and
and and and and you see this culture of
repudiation i mean here in in in not
here you're in canada i'm in the states
in savannah now but you know the the
chateau laurier i think i misspoke
recently called it the the frontenac
which is in quebec but in ottawa you
know the chateau laurier there's been a
a desire to expand this sort of
beautiful sort of neo-gothic building um
and it went through six rounds of
approval to finally uh be uh to
make uh a set of plans that would meet
the local architectural
uh uh
or review board whatever it was and i
thought well it can't be that bad you
know it's gone through that and i mean
this structure is abhorrent it looks
like a a cross between a uh
a verizon server firm and an american
penitentiary i mean it is just a it is a
declaration that there that there is no
higher order you know in edinburgh
they're tearing all those out eh there
is edinburgh is an unbelievable
beautiful beautiful city the the whole
central
mile of it square mile essentially is a
unesco world heritage site and it's
marred by
random placements of 1970s brutalist
architecture
and that they're just horrible it's it's
complete lack of regard for the
architectural context and
they're all being torn out and replaced
thank god
so
well this architectural idea so back to
the cathedral you know what's really
interesting about
a cathedral with let's say christ as
pentecreator on the ceiling is spray
spread against the ceiling is that it's
not the state
that's portrayed up there right it's not
a it's not a map of the country it's not
even a map of the world it's not a
geographical locale or a political
institution it's the transcendent
individual
and you know
it's just not obvious to me it's a it
seems obvious to me that that's correct
that and that if it isn't the
transcendent individual then it becomes
the state and as soon as it the
transcendent becomes the state then we
have a catastrophe
and i don't see any difference between
the insistence that our identity is
predicated on our group membership i
don't see any real difference between
that and the insistence that we're just
handmaidens of the state it's a
totalitarian insistence and i think part
of that too is maybe you know i learned
from jung that
as soon as you posit an ideal you also
specify a judge and the more
the higher the idea the more severe the
judgment
because of your distance from the ideal
and so part of what we're seeing too
might be a rebellion against the
awful
requirements of that ideal
but that doesn't justify that doesn't
justify the rebellion
because if it's really the ideal then if
you don't act it out you you fail to act
it out at your peril
and then we need to have a serious
conversation about the metaphysical
about the
about the practical implications of the
idea of this ideal i mean if if we've
had this conversation about the
transcendent individual as the ideal
against which we should all be judged
and and to which we should struck that
we should strive to emulate
is there
is there any relationship between that
ideal and the structure of reality
itself because that's the that's the
100 question so to speak
you know we we have a human ideal and
you could say
merely psychologically maybe even merely
biologically that that's something we
originated that's that's part of our
biological nature that's expressed in
this ideal and it's nothing more than
that but you could also say well perhaps
it is something more than that perhaps
it's reflective of the structure of
being itself
i mean it depends on our
position in the cosmos you know we are
self-conscious we are that which
reflects being itself or perhaps even
makes it possible it's not that obvious
what our role is it might not be so
trivial
despite our mortality
well i would
say that not only
it is as you say but we can know it to
be as you say i mean this is what the
whole uh history uh in some sense of of
literature and philosophy and theology
is about is a is a and i want to insist
on this it is a rational
uh grappling with
these questions
realities and indeed truths
um
uh i want to come back to something in a
minute but just on this topic
you know one way into this is to
reflect on the
the fact that that reality is not zero
sum
that of course we know this economically
you were talking jordan a minute ago
about you know free you know the the
voluntary exchange of of of regulated
that is to say a contractually governed
uh uh marketplace
um that that in this exchange
you know
it's not
zero sum we all end up over time better
um but you also see this naturally in
the the evolution of the diversity of
species of languages of cultures you've
uh written beautifully about uh play as
orienting the child in relation to a
deepening reciprocity with others we
know this in terms of knowledge i mean
you know how can it be that in a
conversation i can be wrong
and be shown to be wrong and that be a
net gain for me i mean you know i
the whole
the whole
point of free dialogue is that we can
learn from we can learn in our not
knowing that the conversation is not
zero sum that even in the in our in our
speech we know this in terms of
forgiveness that even our betrayals of
beautiful things can become deepening
engagements with what we have betrayed
if we have the humility to see it
and
so then you know i think
you know that
leads one to
you know what geez you can go back you
can go at the level of subatomic
particles in physics i had a pleasure of
talking with freeman dyson uh before he
died
and you know dyson will say very clearly
that against the determinists you know
some of the rational optimists are
pretty religiously determinist in their
in their world view um you know
and they want to marshal modern science
as as as saying that their determinism
is what science teaches uh but that joe
dyson who was a subatomic physicist at
the highest level uh
expressly said the opposite he said that
the electron
that you know you the essentially he
says that the electron is free that
consciousness is not an epiphenomenon
that at the very most detailed
level of subatomic particles things are
not
determinist and the reason i want to go
all the way down to that level is
because you can go down to the lowest
level resolution then you can back up to
the to the higher level and see that
there is a non-zero sum nature to what
is real and then you have to ask
yourself
is it good to live in relation to
to
what is true or should i live in a
delusion and we say well it's better to
live in relation to what's true than to
live in relation to a delusion and and
and then you say well what would it mean
then for me
to
live in relation to this this positive
sum this essential reciprocity which i
think is really what the christian view
of the trinity is about this essential
reciprocity which is the bedrock of all
reality what would it mean to live in
relation to that what would it mean to
to to remember that and you know
one can approach that in any number of
different ways but certainly that is
what what prayer is that is what all
spiritual exercises are that's what
perhaps walking in nature can be that's
what what any kind of meditative
activity intellectual or physical is a
recollecting of the self
in the deepest way to what is most real
and i know you've written for example
about about gratitude and i love your
words about gratitude uh because it's an
inversion of the burden it's not that it
all comes down to us but actually just
the opposite that we
we place ourselves in the hands
of
the
eternal
reciprocity
that gathers us up and puts us back
together
and i think that this frankly is is a
deeply rational standpoint that can be
shown to be despite my not making it
very articulately here today shown to be
true in economics in physics in biology
in sociology and certainly in all of the
higher order uh spheres of human knowing
this is the nature of what of what
we are and and what
the world is and this is where you know
your
your image of the pantocrator you know i
think this comes back to this because
because what
fundamentally is going on there is that
you know the logos is in us
you know it's actually in us that's why
when you talk about the divine
significance of truth and speech
uh that you know we are made to
understand ourselves in relation to the
whole that is an intrinsic human need
and an intrinsic human ability and and i
think that you know this is where you
know you know my life is about trying to
in whatever small way i can you open if
if the nihilists darken the horizon and
close off in the way the brutalist
architecture does close off what we're
allowed to become and understand
ourselves as then i think the work of
our time is to open it back up and and
and and that is really what the
humanities are fundamentally about you
can go back to you know one of the
things i despise about the current
structure of the academy is it acts as
though you know these things are just
for the few
but you know you'll think about you know
homer i mean homer was the mode of
educating the greeks for you know a
thousand years the pantheon was right
there on the highest hill where everyone
could see it same with gothic
architecture you know j.s bach perhaps
the greatest musician who ever lived was
a parish church musician anyone i
presume could walk in the doors and
listen to his to his to his to his
cantatas i mean dickens when dickens
wrote i i've heard recently people would
line the docks
to wait to see what was the next you
know what was the next installment of
dickens and so what what i think you
know most fundamentally is that the the
antidote to the spiritual crisis
civilizational cultural crisis we're
living in is is is is is
really fundamentally
simple in at least it's what we can
state it as and that is to to open the
horizon again to turn the lights back on
and what that means is to turn them on
so that individuals can better come to
understand themselves in relation to
these higher order realities in the
image of which they are made and in
relation to which their fundamental
realization essentially depends
so we have
so
there's critiques of let's say
thought in relationship to the ideal the
freudian critique of religious structure
that
it's infantile
and and perhaps that's a consequence of
the hypothesis of the divine afterlife
that awaits us all
freud regarded that as an infantile
response to the reality of death and
then there's the marxist criticism that
religion only serves power and it's the
opiate of the masses
but there's
i i it's striking to me how poorly the
alternative position has been defended
given its unbelievable power i mean look
we all seem to recognize within
ourselves that we have moral culpability
as far as i can tell because i've never
met anyone who hasn't tortured
themselves to a tremendous degree as a
consequence of their own perceived
inadequacies in relationship to the
ideal
i see that people take the deepest
pleasure that's possible in life in the
facilitation of the development of
others i don't believe that
i believe that's wisdom to notice that
to say well it isn't the
the service to my
momentary desires for pleasure or even
comfort for that matter where i'm going
to find the deepest significance
life-sustaining significance that keeps
me away from
nihilistic hell and and the desire to
destroy and hurt it's it's going to be
something like service to the greater
good and primarily in the form of
well other people in their longest
possible term interests and that we have
not only a divine responsibility to do
that but a divine capacity to do that
that if not manifested
or cripples us spiritually and and
physically for that matter
and
i mean the ultimate significance of that
remains unknowable but i don't see any
logical flaws in that in the
in the proposition i mean i looked at
the manner in which the mesopotamians
built their savior marduk
marduk has eyes all the way around his
head and he speaks magic words the the
cosmos comes into being and disappears
as a consequence of his utterances and
like there's this
sense emerging in mesopotamia as the
consequence of the aggregation of all
these cultures that the highest order
being is extraordinarily attentive hence
the all encircling eyes and is capable
of the deepest and most profound speech
and that's not a realization that's in
any means trivial the mesopotamians had
wars between all of their
representations of their gods and what
they elevated to the highest position
was this all-seeing
truth-speaking capacity that also went
forward and confronted chaos and built
the world as a consequence and the
influence of that set of ideas or the
derivation from the set same set of
ideas for the
jewish conception of yahweh is quite
clear and you see the same thing
emerging in greece with with the
building of a pantheon of gods and the
proposition that something occupies the
apex something apollonian or something
of that nature
and then
you see that revolution take place
with the dawn of christianity and the
insistence that
there's something fundamental about
consciousness and
spoken
and and what's and and the spoken truth
that is constitutive of reality and you
ask yourself well do you believe that
and the answer is well you treat people
like you believe that because you hold
them responsible for the consequences of
their utterances and you judge their
character on the basis of what they say
and you and on whether or not they act
out what they say and so we hold each
other to these standards with everything
that we do and we berate ourselves when
we don't live up to them and i don't
understand how it is that we can be said
not to believe it
now you know there's the dogmatic
element the hypothesis for example that
christ is literally the son of god and i
mean my knowledge runs out very very
rapidly when speculating about such
things but i'm certainly
it certainly seems to me that
christianity has at least been a very
long conversation about what the nature
of the good is and that that's spilled
out into the humanities and and
underlies our culture and that
that
that that has very little to do with the
expression of power it's it's the it's
not the right lens through which to view
things it's devastating it's wrong it's
cynical
and i think it appeals to envy and and
the desire to tear down
well well i i i i think i think that
the well two things i would say just
very quickly jordan the first is that
you know uh we have immense resources in
the uh in our own past and in the past
of every culture i mean one of the
things i love about your work is how
syncretist it is you know here you've
moved
in the last five minutes and you moved
from marduk to you know and the
pantocrator to uh uh to uh the greeks
and and good on you for doing it i mean
that's that's uh i think uh i want to
say that
uh
you say people have not been good at
making the counter argument uh well um
uh
you've been very very good at making the
counter argument and uh the millions of
people who've had their lives uh touched
and ennobled and deepened by
uh
by um
taking seriously the things you point
towards uh are proof of that um i
you know i think relative to our
spiritual cultural uh crisis uh we
should not pretend that we don't have
resources i mean it's as if uh it's as
if
you know the situation is is if you were
to give young people uh uh
the challenge of
building something beautiful and if you
were to
if you were to say well you're
absolutely not allowed to look at or
have any knowledge of any previous
building well the results are not going
to be very good but as soon as you say
and you can go back to palladio and
vitruvius and look at all these models
and discover all of the things that they
give you i mean the results
will be amazing
and so i what i want to
i want to drive towards a kind of uh
optimism not rooted in in kind of
uh you know silly blindness about the
depth of our problems but rather
in in the
the the nature of what is most real and
the whole treasure house
of of tools it's like we have these
spotlights from the from the past to
help us understand ourselves and the the
the
the the world around us in philosophy
and religion and literature in
architecture and our in in art and
painting and music i mean for god's
sakes i mean we've got we've got
an unspeakable
treasure house
here and and
the
it may be that as we dig into that we
see
that we uncover ourselves
more and understand ourselves more uh
adequately you know i want to do one
example you know for example i think uh
one thing that is a uh
i live in the in beautiful city very
beautiful city in historic savannah and
i'm live on the edge of a
just absolutely a stunning
civic space uh park called forsyth park
i hope you can come and see it someday
there's a beautiful fountain in the
middle of it and it has these these
these oak trees these live oaks that
were planted by people long dead now
these oaks of
you know one to two to even 300 years uh
old
and
i not infrequently see uh young couples
coming to stand in front of one of the
biggest the biggest oak inside the park
proper
to
uh to get married you know they stand
there with the justice of the peace and
exchange simple vows and i think we have
to ask ourselves
what in the hell is going on there
and it seems to me
you know very beautiful and in a way
very simple it's that they wish that
their vows
they are aspiring to be to each other in
some way as the oak tree as
able to live up to
the
um
the love that they are
called to
and they want to instantiate that uh by
uh
by that's where you turn to the garden
and the tree in the center yes
yes and act out adam and eve
yeah reborn
yes yes
the the incorporation of the host is the
is the embodiment it's the incarnation
of christ within that's what it's acting
out that's the idea i mean in some sense
it's it's the consumption of the saving
element but the saving element is
actually a mode of being and this isn't
hit home it's like look what the
church the church demands
everything of you yeah absolutely
everything and
then the reason that that people are
leaving is because
that adventure isn't being put before
them it's like look you can have your
cars and your money and all of that but
that's nothing compared to the adventure
that you could be going on
yes i i wish you'd preach to our people
because i think you're absolutely right
about that uh
the language we'd use is
be a saint
that's what that's the ordinary goal of
every baptized person is to be a saint a
saint means someone who's holy or
utterly conformed to christ now press
that to be conformed to christ means
you're willing to go
into the dysfunction of the world to
bear its pain and to bear to it the ever
greater divine mercy and love now fill
in the blank francis of assisi mother
teresa may be in our time like when we
were younger if someone said well who's
a living saint we all would have said
mother teresa well what did she do
she went into the worst slum in the
world i'd been there
and she bore the suffering of of of the
world
literally picking up the dying and
bearing their disease and bearing their
psychological suffering and
and she she took on herself the wounds
of jesus
but then think about you know the smile
of mother teresa she brought to that
place the ever greater more super
abundant mercy of christ that's being a
saint and you're dead right i think
we're not sufficiently calling our
people to do that i can tell you one
thing i've experienced and this is this
is really something to see
i spoke in about 150 cities sequentially
with a day or to in between and it to to
large audiences three to ten thousand
all the time something like that
and
i always
paid attention to the audience
singly because i was always talking to
one person at a time but also on mass
you know to see to hear
because if if the words are in landing
in the right place and hypothetically
emanating from the proper source then
there's silence
and sometimes that silence can be
dramatic and that's why people say well
you could have heard a pin drop it's no
one's moving because their attention is
100
gripped by whatever just happened and
one thing that reliably elicited that
was the proposition that the meaning
that sustains you and protects you from
corruption during suffering is to be
found in responsibility
and people that and and i thought i
thought part of the reason that that
produced silence was because no one says
that now they say happiness or they say
rights or they say privileges or or or
they say reward or something like that
they don't say
pick up the heaviest load you can care
and carry and care for that matter and
stumble forward and i've seen people cut
those ideas and put them on t-shirts and
and play with them and and so
it's not that the church is asking too
little of its people
i'm recommending that we remember the
that meaning in life and this is also
something i'm doing empirical work on
right that meaning in life is mostly
bound right at the non-propositional
level and it does feed into things like
sacredness i think reverence is the
proper virtue of awe reverence is the
virtue that helps us appropriate well
reverence means it does hold as hold in
ritual and is hold as a marker as a
as a pointer for ritual emulation i
think it's i think
that's embodiment that's and that's the
that's the pulling in of that
personality into the self i think that's
right but i think what ah see ah is
really interesting because ah okay so
you can measure this r is one of the few
instances where people's sense of self
and egocentrism is is shrunk and they
but they find it a positive experience
and they want it to continue uh right
well that's that's how what we
experience in relationship to our
current ego when we hypothesize our
ideal as well
i i think that's right and that goes to
i mean those are the same things because
there are capture or is the ideal
aw is our unconscious ideal capturing us
think about it it's the spirit within so
imagine this you you already admitted so
to speak that we're you know
canotic representations of the central
animating spirit of the ages
and that speaks
from our unconscious because it's
it's embodied within us and then it
finds its it finds its grip on us in in
awe in admiration would you say though
uh so there's a question like would you
say that it's not only the end the
unconscious within us but the
unconscious without us because i think
yes what are you doing
it's the unconscious in the books behind
you yes and also the unconscious in the
world because i think part of what
what we're trying to do i think we got
too locked into
the gnosis the notion of the sacred as
perfection completion this is one of my
critiques of plato although i'm normally
a lover of plato and i think you can see
in the mystics and in many traditions
this is a claim i can back up but i'm
just going to throw it out there
right even in even in jonathan's
tradition eastern orthodoxy is the
sacred the good becoming better well the
sacred is an inexhaustibleness right and
yes that's why i'm asking that question
yes because when i've had visions of
heaven heaven is a place that's perfect
and getting better
well okay well
okay let me give you my sense the place
where i i don't have visions but the
place where i experience what i'm
talking about i wouldn't recommend them
necessarily yeah
well i mean um
we can compare altered states of
consciousness another time perhaps um oh
yeah okay
if you'd really like to do that would
you
um
well
let me just finish the the point i was
making so for me don't be before on to
another universe you mean
yeah
see for me i tell people that plato is
sacred which does not mean i cannot that
i can't question him it does not mean
that i can't disagree with him it means
the following plato transforms me i go
out and live my life for a while the
world then changes me because of the way
i've been changed i come back and i see
things in plato i didn't see before and
then i go back to the world the thing is
i when the bible does that for people
yes and and that's why the bible is
sacred and and and
and what plato i think argues and and
what taoism argues and i think
christianity argues where there's also
the book of nature there's always the
two books of revelation you can actually
experience that with respect to nature i
don't particularly like that term but
you can experience that with right where
the world i think introverts do that in
particular i i that's a hypothesis of
mine i don't have evidence for it but
i've noticed my introverted clients need
to be renewed by nature when i've tried
to reduce this i mean that experience of
awe so we went to a co we went to a
whole conference on that so
if you see someone that you really
admire
that shades into awe and you can see
that in in the effect that celebrities
have on the on the public it's a peril
it can be paralyzing so
the admiration there's a continuum
between admiration and awe
and then you can easily
make the case i think that
admiration is the felt sense of the
instinct to
imitate
so you see children maybe they'll hear a
worship someone
and then they
they'll imitate them they'll copy them
they find someone who's in that zone of
proximal development and they start to
copy them or they'll take on the
identity of a hero or heroine in a movie
my little granddaughter who's three for
a year now literally a year
she has two names scarlett and and and
ellie elizabeth and we kind of call her
one or the other and if you ask her
is she scarlet she'll say yes
is she ellie yes is she pocahontas
yes
is she scarlet ellie or pocahontas
pocahontas
one year now she watched that disney
movie over and over and she has a
pocahontas doll but and but she's picked
that figure and that's
quasi-mythological figure obviously not
a historical figure she's picked that as
her
identity
and i see that as
we can we can imitate people we talked
about reality and hyper reality before
well you can find someone you admire and
they're real or you can find someone
who's a mythological figure and they're
hyper real
and the hyper reality is so adaptive
that imitating the hyper reel is more
adaptive than imitating the real and
that's to me the that's the essence of
the religious instinct it's to derive
the hyper real
and then to imitate that and i think
that's what worship means essentially
all with everything stripped away and so
that's a profound instinct because human
beings are unbelievable mimics i mean
that
that's a very
underappreciated element of our
cognitive architecture a fundamental
element
and
that
that instinct to admire and experience
off facilitates that mimicry and that
increases the probability of the
manifestation of complex adaptive
behavior
okay so
and then what does what
that makes of the religious domain
something real as far as i'm concerned
even real from the biological sense
but that deepens the mystery of the
involvement of the psychedelics in that
like are they are they parasitizing that
are they like cocaine hyper stimulates
the psychomotor stimulant system
well does psychedelics hyper stimulate
the imitation awe system
and and is that an illusion or is it in
fact
a revelation of something deeper
yet
yeah just circle back to the ontological
question so just recently i listened to
a lecture uh that francis collins gave
now so francis collins you may
recognize is director of the national
institutes on health
and he was also the
director of the human
genome project you know so
so he's a strongly credentialed
a scientist as one can have
and yet
he's uh
absolutely confirmed christian
and so he was giving a lecture on
the reconciliation of
i think he called it harmonization of a
scientific and
religious worldview
uh but he was he was laying out
his arguments for the existence of
of god
and one of them
is
what it would be his claim and it's an
interesting claim and you could argue it
but the existence of moral law
that there is an absolute moral law look
you know you i looked at jack pancep's
work you know and he shows that you see
complex morality emerging rats in play
play iterated play which is a crucial
issue right what pattern of behavior
is sustainably optimal across repeated
social interactions well you know you
hear all these post-modern critiques say
of more of of hierarchical structure
because of its its predication on
power i think no no corrupt hierarchies
are predicated on power
functional hierarchies are predicated on
reciprocal
uh on reciprocity on productive
reciprocity you know i was talking to
this
this joker willing who was the commander
of fallujah in in in in
in the
20 years ago and he's a real warrior
type you know like a real intimidating
person physically and mentally for that
matter um
he talked about his navy seal training
and
you know he said well we were taught it
was pounded into us to have the back of
the guy next to us
it wasn't like every powerful
clambering ape for himself
not at all
in these intensely competitive
hierarchies which would be you'd think
as pure a manifestation of the power
motive as would be possible power is not
the guiding ethos and he said quite
clearly no your men won't attend to you
unless it's reciprocal you they have to
know you have their backs
and he and so and he made also a very
sophisticated case for the development
of verbal intelligence and the ability
to communicate in strategizing and also
in taking care of your team and so i
don't believe that
um
so what am i getting at in relationship
to your to your last point
this this religious
this emergent ethic this natural law
okay so imagine now
hierarchies are organized around an
ethical principle if they're to be
stable and productive across long spans
of time
and a pattern that pattern emerges
across culturally it's reciprocal
productivity it's something like that
it's more there's more to it than that
okay now
you're selected for your success in
those hierarchies based on your ability
to manifest that pattern
because that'll push you up the
hierarchy that increases as far as i can
tell that increases your attractiveness
as a potential mate substantially
and so i think you can make a very deep
biological case for the
even for the
emergent evolution of an ethical sense
and and i think that does speak to
people in the voice of their conscience
and that that is part of
but then you think well if that's part
of existence how deep a part is it
how built in is it
you know and i i don't i and that i
suppose depends to some degree on how
crucial consciousness is to being
okay so back to back to the gentleman
that you were discussing he was talking
about a natural ethic
yeah uh well
i think uh
as as a pointer to god something
absolute about the nature of
what moral law is
and from that standpoint
uh if if you're willing to go that route
then
maybe these experiences are actually
pointing to something that is absolute
and true
and informative
do you think that's true
i don't know
i'm a scientist
it's fine to be investigating it you
know what yeah no i'm going to pin you
down no
let's see
uh you know my i'm trained as a
scientist my default is uh
to be deeply
curious and to be deeply skeptical so
right which is the right right attitude
towards yeah and so my
my response always is that i believe in
the data and so
and so that remains an open question but
it's certainly fun to toy with as a uh
as an all
as an alternative framing of what's
going on i mean we're in the middle of
this huge huge mystery
i i understand and appreciate the
symbolic significance of the ideal human
being
and that finds its embodiment and i took
these ideas in large part from jung and
eric neumann
that that christ is a represent christ
is at least a representation of the
ideal
man whatever that is and and we we all
interestingly enough we all seem to have
an ideal
and we and that i or that ideal has us
right and that's where it's very
interesting to consider the role of
conscience because
your conscience will call you out on
your behavior
and so it seems to function as something
that's somewhat independent or at least
is something that you can't fully
voluntarily control because if you could
voluntarily control it
then you just tell the pesky little
bastard to go away
or to pat you on the back continually
because
there must be few things in life more
pleasurable than being a fully committed
narcissist
to really believe that everything that
you do is right and that you're a good
person and i suppose if you could wave a
magic wand and rearrange your mind so
that it was constantly telling you that
you'd do it but you don't seem to be
able to do that in relationship to your
conscience
it trips you up
and so
and so it tells you when you're not
living up to
your own ideal and that means that you
have an ideal and you don't even know
what the hell it is but you certainly
know when you transgress against it and
i know that there's a strong line of
christian thinking that's identified
the conscience with divinity
sometimes with christ inside sometimes
with the holy spirit
and those are very interesting
conceptualizations but you can think of
them psychologically and you can even
think about them biologically you know
to some degree because we're so social
if we
don't manifest an appropriate moral
reciprocity
we're going to become alienated from our
fellows and we won't survive and we'll
suffer and die and we won't we certainly
won't find a partner and and
have children successfully and
so to some degree the conscience can be
viewed as the voice of
reciprocal society within and that's a
perfectly reasonable biological
explanation
but
but the thing is is the deeper you go
into biology the more it shades into
something that appears to be religious
because you start
analyzing the fundamental structure of
the psyche itself
and and
it becomes something
well
it becomes something with a pow with
with a with a with
with a power that transcends your
ability to resist it
so okay so you can think about christ
from a psychological perspective and
the crit the critic
my critic this particular critic that
i've been reading
said well that that doesn't
differentiate christ much from a whole
sequence of dying and resurrecting
mythological gods and of course people
have made that
claim
in comparative religion joseph campbell
did that and jung to a lesser degree i
would say but campbell did that
but
the
difference and c.s lewis pointed this
out as well the difference between those
mythological gods and christ was that
there's a
there's a representation of
there's a historical representation of
his of of his existence as well now you
can debate whether or not that's genuine
you can debate about whether or not he
actually lived and whether there's
credible objective evidence for that but
it doesn't matter in some sense because
this well it does but
there's a sense in which it doesn't
matter because there's still a
historical story and so what you have in
the figure of christ is an actual person
who actually lived plus
a myth and in some sense christ is the
union of those two things the problem is
is i probably believe that but i don't
know i don't i'm amazed at my own belief
and i don't understand it like
because i've seen
sometimes
the objective world
and the narrative world touch
you know that's union synchronicity
and i've seen that many times in my own
life
and so in some sense i believe it's
undeniable you know we have a narrative
sense of the world for me that's been
the world of morality that's the world
that tells us how to act
it's real like we treat it like it's
real it's not the objective world
but the narrative and the objective
world touch and the ultimate example of
that in principle is supposed to be
christ
but i don't know what to and that seems
to me oddly plausible
yeah
but i still don't know what to make of
it it's too it partly because it's too
terrifying
a reality to
fully believe i don't even know what
would happen to you if you fully
believed it
this critic
said that the mere psychologization of
christ
was insufficient because and you made
the same case in some sense that
it doesn't make sense unless the
narrative and the
objective world truly touch and i think
you could debate that because i think
that there's some
utility there could argue to be be some
utility in a secular version of the hero
myth you know that the best way to cope
with existence is to
for
to tell the truth and to face what you
don't know forthrightly and that will
enable you to orient yourself
within our finite and bounded existence
that ends with our death more
properly more accurately more advisedly
than any other route
i've seen
people from orthodox priests to you know
the more the most uh protestant
protestant you can imagine
recognize in the way that you represent
reality something that has value
something that has value because
you're you are manifesting that
that pattern like what you're saying is
is true
uh
but i think that i think that
if we if we if we take seriously this
the problem the relationship between
attention psyche and the way the world
reveals itself to us
then it scales up
it scales up after that it jumps up a
level and
it also scales up in terms of
because one of the things that
one of the things that that you talk
about like looking up to the star and
looking up to the highest thing you can
look at and then aiming towards that you
know
once again one of the things that that
does for is that
the first thing you do is actually where
it's a form it's attention that people
don't like the word worship it's a form
of reverence a form of veneration you
submit yourself to that aim so it's not
just that you see the aim and that you
aim for it you actually have to submit
yourself to that which is to what you're
aiming and so that sacrifice to it
exactly and you have to sacrifice to it
so
that's why
let's say the religious version of this
has to move towards the highest possible
aim and also one that we can do together
because like the lower aims like you
could call them something like lower
gods let's say or angels or whatever you
want to call them like these lower aims
they have value but they're all
fragmented
but for this to stack up we need to be
able to look towards the same
image we need to look towards the same
aim and that will bind us together and
so we don't we don't all then we don't
also end up being just kind of
individuals who have the weight of the
world on our shoulders but we're a
communion of saints we're communion of
people who are
submitted to aiming towards worshiping
the same
point yeah and i believe that that's
necessary and and i've i've had some
profound experiences which i can't
really relate here that
of
of the necessity for that community is
that this whatever our fundamental moral
load is
immense though it is um crushing though
it is even
um
requires
the participation of others so even if
you were the perfect you
you would need other people
to be along with you it's a collective
enterprise even though it's an
individualistic even though it requires
the perfection it requires
as much perfection as is possible at the
individual level
that's not enough there has to be that
communal element as well you need help
we all need help to aim as high the
highest aim requires communal endeavor
yeah and it's also because it actually
is the way that everything works you
know it's like the chair aiming to be a
chair is a is a constitutive of parts
which are joined together towards a a
same goal and therefore hold together as
a being and manifest the chairness of
the chair and that's the same with you
you have all these thoughts right you
have all these feelings all these these
contradicting things inside you and you
need by aiming up towards you know the
the
i mean i believe that the
image of christ let's say by aiming
towards the image of christ
you constitute your being into that
being that's able to attend to sacrifice
to love
and then that scales up with people i
agree well i think you are i mean this
is another something else i tried to
point out to sam
um
you are
you're aiming you're either aiming at
christ or something lesser
yeah or if things get really out of hand
you're aiming at something opposite and
you don't want to be doing that but and
this is a matter of definition in some
sense and
it's actually not impossible to
understand is that you aim at something
better
generally speaking i mean maybe you're
out to cause pain but forget about that
you you aim at something better
you wouldn't do it unless it was better
in fact it it virtually defines better
like the whole idea of better is
predicated on the idea that there's an
aim that's beyond you and then the
highest of those aims is the amalgamate
the highest aim is the amalgam a
amalgamation of all higher aims and
that's a perfect mode of being
and and that by definite that's a
psychological perspective again that by
definition is christ and then but then
there seems to be something too
convenient about cs lewis's insistence
that that also had to manifest itself
concretely in reality at one point in
history and i'm not
like i
i don't understand why
i should believe that
and i don't i tend not to believe things
without a why
there's always a why
and yeah and i there's there's a hurdle
there that i that that
well that i waver on constantly because
i well i already said that
you're when you think these things
through
at least my experience as being if you
think them through sufficiently you end
up with
the choice between impossible
alternatives and so yeah
but it has to do
one of the ways to see it maybe is is
it has to do with the recognizing of the
goodness of the world or the goodness of
creation
that that the world is capable
of manifesting these patterns right so
if you want to understand for example
the big conflict between the early
gnostics and the christians that's what
it was all about
because the gnostics basically wanted a
disincarnated christ they were saying
you know and they viewed the world as
utterly fallen as having no value having
to be escaped having to be fled in every
way
whereas christianity posits that
it's a non-dual it's a non-dual
proposition it's saying
it's it all comes together
that's the that's the promise it all
comes together and so
it has to come down
right and so it has to come down at
every level and not only does it have to
come down into the person of christ
who's incarnated but that person has to
go down down into death to the very
bottom of the world you know to the
belly of the leviathan and then come
back up
and so the whole world is declared as
once again
declared as
being capable of participating in this
good and so and so you could say well
maybe maybe it wasn't that one maybe it
wasn't you know it's like why would it
be that particular
particular
place where it happened but it had to be
that's the place that's the story i mean
that's where that there is no other
story like that story that we have
and and so
once you recognize that this is part of
the declaration that the world does
embody these patterns
that it leads to this it leads to
the the this this story of of a man who
embodied them absolutely
and is bringing us in him to also embody
them in a way that will transform us
you know like the the ultimate goal of
of orthodox vision of christianity is is
theosis it's to become god
to become god through through
transformation and participation in god
so that's the final goal of everything
is to become
participant in the divine where does
your insistence that values are part of
the structure of being
like where does that find its limit
because that the classic limit of that
is something like
is
in fact the definition of the utmost
place of value in some sense is almost
indistinguishable from the claim that
there is a god
and so
a god is not the same as an engineering
god and i i take enormous pains in the
book it costs me more than anything i've
ever written to write the chapter called
the sense of the sacred in which i try
to
help people to a place where
they can understand why people use this
extraordinarily difficult word god
you know it's not a satisfactory term
but it's the term we have to have to
name
an aspect of our experience that if we
don't name it disappears from our lives
and that's not to say that there isn't
something there that is that merits
whatever we mean when we say divine i
mean we haven't defined we haven't
defined what we mean by divine and we're
back in the nets of language we're
trapped in the nets of language as
shelling said
but what i'm suggesting is that
as whitehead suggested and come on
whitehead
was also the co-author with russell of
the principia mathematica he wasn't um
a fantasist he had this i think
incredibly deep idea
that whatever one likes to call the
divinity
god whatever
is
the thing that
the cosmos has relation with relation is
at the core of being i even argued that
relation is prior to the relata prior to
the things that are related that sounds
nonsense how can you relate how can you
have a relation if there isn't anything
yet to relate
but there's a wonderful image called um
in indian mythology called indra's net
which covers the universe
and in it the idea is that the filaments
of the net exist before
the net before the crossing points which
are the things we see and on those
crossing points there are little gems
which reflect every other gem in the net
and that's a that would take a very long
time to unpack but perhaps it can set
things going in people's minds but the
idea i gesture to the right hemisphere
is that relation
is prior to anything at all really and
that therefore the the whatever you mean
by god and whatever we mean by the
cosmos
are in some sort of dynamic relation
which is an evolving one in which the
outcome is excitingly not known if it
were known it would all be some horrible
possibly sadistic um play uh by an all
mighty all-knowing god i mean then
look i'm going to be talking to rowan
williams shortly but i don't want to go
go into all that i mean by that i don't
think god is omniscient and omnipotent
but i don't think he's not either just
in the same way i don't think he's green
and i don't think he's not green i think
the terms are wrong uh but you know we
can go there if we want them later or
another day but the thing
what i'm saying is that these that god
is discovering
becoming unfulfilling whatever god is
through the relationship which
classically in most religions is
described as love which is after all
just a like a form of gravity in the
world of of life and emotion rather than
just in the world of of um the so-called
inanimate um
so
that therefore we are coming into being
god is coming into being and we're
necessary to one another's coming into
being it's not that god does a bit to us
and then we do a bit back to god it's
like i've read a very good book i keep
mentioning it by a young microbiologist
in america called kritishama called
interdependence and she argues very
importantly that it's not just that um
certainly it's not just that an animal
or an organism molds its environment nor
is it just good enough to recognize that
while an animal
affects and shapes its environment the
environment shapes the the animal or the
organism but that this is not a you know
uh turn-by-turn process it's not that
the animal shapes the environment should
then
uh in its turn shapes the the animal
it's an entirely
simultaneous process of coming into
being of co-creation if you like now
this idea of simultaneous coming into
being is an ancient one but i think it's
a very deep one philosophically and a
very important one
so that accounts for your objection to
the idea of the omniscient determining
god
absolutely absolutely because the the
god has
god would have no creation creation is
not really just the unfolding of
something that's already there
the the idea of negative theology is
you fundamentally i wonder if this is
like
uh young circumambulation you
fundamentally understand god by saying
what god is not
but not of course randomly right um what
you're trying to do oh that's sort of
like the god of the gaps well no no no
no no no no no no oh sorry oh no that's
don't apologize we're friends talking
well i don't i don't want to derail the
conversation so
it's been it's been like this and it's
been wonderful it feels to me like doing
tai chi um
no it's more that it's more of a
recognition of not of the god of the
gaps
but of a recognition how our categorical
scheme is always inadequate so for
example is god an object well no that's
wrong is god a subject like the way we
are no that's wrong too that's it right
so god is well god escapes our
categorical right god is by definition
in some sense the what escapes are
categorized because god is supposed to
be the grounding of the intelligibility
that makes the categorical scheme
possible at least that's right but
there's also presence within present
within the category scheme if it's set
up properly so right so so the point
about negative theo that's why it's not
just the god of the gaps the point is
is to see within the category that it's
present within the categories but it's
not capturable within the categories
that's what you're trying to do the
category yeah yes the reality supersedes
the categories which is why you're not
supposed to make idols you're why you're
not supposed to make representations of
you make icons just to to summon
jonathan back into the conversation one
more time you can make icons right and
you've got john luke marion's
distinction between the idol and what's
the what's the distinction the
distinction the icon does not capture
god right that's exactly it it's an
artwork so an artwork is an icon exactly
and propaganda is an idol yes
i would agree with both of those
statements
well isn't that something because
they're they're really in some sense far
astray aren't they but they do map and
so how cool is that so art is art is the
icon
how cool and and propaganda is the idol
exactly man you know and i had these
paintings in my house and they were
melds of the icon and the idol
right because there's all this socialist
realism i have 200 pieces of socialist
realism watching the icon in the idol
fight with each other
well and the problem is they are and i
want to get the entomology of this word
they
at a superficial level of similarity
they can easily be confused they can be
confused
okay yes well that they and i would say
they will
inevitably confused in the absence of
god
well and i because propaganda
like this is something i've been working
on too john is that yeah you know
we make religious
the next thing on the hierarchy if we
don't give to what is religious it's
proper place and i think the new
atheists are beginning to realize this
the amount of the world's evil that's a
consequence of our voluntary moral
insufficiencies is indeterminate you
know so you might say hypothetically
speaking that as part of god's creation
we actually have important work to do
and if we shirk it the consequences are
real
and you might say well that's just an
apology for god and perhaps that's the
case and perhaps there's no god at all
and so what the hell are we talking
about but
but i do think it's an important issue i
mean your life is chara characterized by
a stellar
level of
constant productive creativity
that's that that's you and you're
offering that to the world and that
seems necessary and maybe it's because
the problems are real and important and
and the role we have to play ethically
is of paramount importance truly yeah
why else would we torture ourselves with
conscience and and
i would say that's the flowering of the
religious instinct within you
well
you could describe it as that but then
you know there are phrases i mean you
used a phrase earlier then i i i wanted
to say whoa hang on i'm not sure i know
what that means a higher mode of
existence um i i don't see
i remember having this argument with
john cleese of all people some years ago
he he was a great
lover of the
tibetan book of the dead and gilbran and
people like that and and i've always
found them
slightly hard to take and he talked
about a he i think the phrase he used
was a higher level of consciousness and
i said i don't and again this is my
empiricist thing it sounds cynical and
skeptical it's not meant to be but
what level who's a what describer level
what is a higher mode why higher what's
higher than another are you saying it in
terms of animals
um it's a view it's an old-fashioned
huxley in view of evolution that most
modern uh richard dawkins for example
most modern evolutionary scientists and
and so on the ethologists would would
deprecate to say that there is a higher
level of being a higher mode of
consciousness is it just like saying
well you're better educated you've read
more you know more is it you've somehow
been enlightened a fair clown's effect
as the germans would say which is um
which is not necessarily intellectual
but is somehow spiritual and
if so
show me an example of it show me someone
who has a higher mode of existence than
i do uh or the i can i can answer that i
think to some degree three ways three
ways
one
that higher mode of existence is what
your conscience tortures you for not
attaining right okay okay i don't think
my conscience tortures me for not
attaining is that i was rude to someone
yesterday and i shouldn't have been
right but it's the shouldn't part of it
yes the obligation it's the t exactly
david hume the problem of ought yeah
well and then you think that you think
you think about how it manifests itself
you don't this is why nietzsche was
wrong
you cannot create your own values
right the values impose themselves on
you independent of your will
now maybe there you partic well that's
what your conscience does and good luck
trying to control it this is very
anti-nature isn't it it's well
i'm a great admirer i know you are
that's why i was that's why i made the
point
well opposite to his philosophy but it's
well so jung embarked on a lengthy
critique of nietzsche and it's part of
his work that isn't well known i would
say but and
we'll leave that be except to say that
the psychoanalysts starting with freud
well not really but popularized by freud
and systematized showed that we weren't
masters in our own psychological house
nice there were there were autonomous
entities yes and those would be the
greek gods to some degree that operated
within us and we were which is julian
james's point exactly yes we're in yes
yes i have my problems with jane's but
as a overarching idea there's interest
in it okay so there are things happening
with us and to us in the moral domain
that we cannot control yeah and that's
uh that that stunned me when i first
learned it as a proposition it's oh yes
look at that here's one
what are you interested in
yeah well that grips you
okay number two what does your
conscience bother you about
okay that's you're inadequate by your
own standards now what adequate would
mean
that's a different question but it's
defined negatively by conscience yes
and then
better there's one out that i said i
would lay out three
you can look at jean piaget's work on
developmental psychology the development
of the subject yes
he was a genetic epistemologist
he wanted to do
this is what he wanted to do he wanted
to unite science and religion that was
his goal and he wanted to look at the
empirical development of values and what
he concluded at least in part was that a
moral stance that's better than a
previous moral stance does all the
things that the previous moral stance
does plus something else yes
yes and you can say the same thing no as
a scientific theory i remember i i had a
great i i loved piaget and i
uh his observation was so empirical of
course yes absolutely the development of
the child and the
uh not quite the theory of mind that
wasn't his thing but but but
similar developments and signposts where
people become aware of
self okay so so now piaget looked
specifically at the development of
morality
and he was one of the first people to
emphasize the importance of games yeah
and what he showed what he showed was
that at two years old let's say a child
can only play a game with him or herself
but at three
both children can identify an aim and
then share it in a fictional world and
so that's partly pretend play and the
beginnings of drama and then cooperate
and compete within that domain yeah
and then what happens and the game
theorists have shown this is that
games
out of games morality emerges yeah
there's a result so i'll give you an
example this is a crucial example so if
you pair
juvenile rats together the males
they have to play they have to rough and
tumble play because their prefrontal
cortexes don't develop properly if they
don't anyways they have to play
you pair a big rat in a little rat
teenage rats together and the big rat
will stomp the little rat yeah
first first encounter so then you say
power determines hierarchy
yeah okay but then you pair the routes
multiple times
like 50
then if the big rat doesn't let the
little rat win 30 of the time the little
rat will stop inviting him to play
and so you get an emergent reciprocity
even at the level of the rat yeah
one of the constitutive aspects of how
reality unfolds and how it appears to us
is
something like attention
right it's something there's a hierarchy
of of manifestation because everything
that hap that appears to us in the world
has a an infinite amount of details
right it has an indefinite amount of
ways that you could describe it that you
could angled it by which you could
analyze it
and so
nonetheless the world appears to us
through these hierarchies of meaning
right i always kind of use the example
of a cup or a chair like a chair is is
of just a multitude of things it's a
multitude of parts how is it that we can
say that it's one thing
there's a there's a capacity we have to
attend and this capacity we have to
attend is something like a co-creation
of the world and so the world actually
exists a chair is a good example because
you know you can try to define it
objectively but you end up with bean
bags and stumps and exactly and they
don't have anything in common well
they're both made of matter you know for
whatever that's worth it's pretty
pretty trivial level of commonality but
you can sit on them
yeah and that's what you have there's a
mode of being which they find
well and that's so strange so many of
our object perceptions are
projected modes of being and so even the
objective world is intellectually
contaminated with its utility and then
therefore with morality
exactly and so i think that that's the
key the key is that once you understand
that the world manifests itself through
attention and that consciousness has a
place to play in actually the way in
which the world
reveals itself and so you can you can
try to posit a world outside of that
first person perspective but it's it's
good
it's it's a deluded uh activity well
it's also it's
very very difficult because you don't
you don't know what to make of something
like time
because time has an
inerratically subjective element and
duration which is different than time i
mean time is
kind of like the average rate at which
things change but duration is something
like the felt sense of that time and
if you take away this objectivity it
isn't obvious what to do with time and i
think physicists stumble over this all
the time so to speak
so and this is something that this this
intermingling of value and fact was
something that i never thought i never
thought i made much traction with with
harris with sam harris
he he didn't seem to me to be willing to
admit
how saturated the world of fact is
inevitably with value and i actually
think he's denying the science at that
point because for everything i know
about perceptual psychology
there's a great book called uh um
vision as a
oh god now i can't remember the name of
the books that's memory trouble i'll
remember it no worries
the idea is that
if that is true
then there are certain things which come
out of that there are certain necessary
uh
things down the road from that that
insight which is that attention plays a
part in the way the world lays itself
out um
and that one of them and one of them is
that the stuff that the world is made of
is partly something like attention
something like consciousness and that
has a pattern and that pattern is the
same pattern as stories
it just it's just it doesn't lay itself
out exactly the same but things exist
with a pattern which is similar to
stories they have identities they have
centers they have margins they have
exceptions
and that's how stories lay themselves
out like so a story happens in time
how an identity let's say
uh is broken down and then reconstructed
you could say that that's basically the
story of every story how something
breaks down and is reconstructed and so
that is a way for us to perceive uh the
identity of things and so if the world
is made of this
then
it's actually
it's actually our world our secular
world which is a strange aberration on
how
reality used to exist for every culture
and every time from the beginning of
time which is to take that for granted
to take for granted that
something that they didn't call it
consciousness but intelligence and
attention are part of how the world lays
itself out and it lays itself out in
modes of being
and one of the things that comes out of
it is not only that but
like you said
it's not only that you have ideas but
it's that ideas have you or that it's
not only that you engage in modes of
being it's that modes of being
have you
and that recognition
means that the first level of
the first level of
attention to that looks something like
worship
it looks like celebration
it looks like a it
it's like uh the the thing which makes
the let's say the national hockey league
so successful
has more to do with celebration than
just a bunch of guys on skates on a
piece of ice you know throwing a puck
around there's a celebration of the
purpose of that thing and it manifests
itself
through a bunch of stuff which one is
like a trophy that stands in the middle
on the top of a bunch of on a stand and
everybody looks at it and kisses it and
and and so there's this this veneration
yeah and there's
the hockey league example is very
interesting because it's a
it's a it's a social game
and you know all the players
are they're attempting to aim right
right so there's a symbolic element to
that sin is misplaced aim
and so you hit the you hit the small
space in the net
blocked though it may be by your enemies
and everyone celebrates that and you do
that in cooperation with other people
and in competition with other people and
if you do it properly not only are you a
brilliant player from a technical
perspective but you're also a great
sport and so there's an ethic there and
a
and and this is why people are so upset
when hockey players or any other pro
athlete does something immoral in their
personal life is because it violates the
the ethic that that's being celebrated
as a consequence of this great game yeah
and right so you can see that that the
striving for an ideal mode of being the
religious striving for an ideal mode of
being is central to what it is that
makes hockey um addictive
that's right
yeah it necessarily and and so god i saw
that pro wrestling there's a great
documentary uh
bret hart
called hitman hearts one of the best
documentaries i've ever seen and it
portrays pro wrestling as a stark
religious
battle between the forces of good and
evil and bret hart who at one point was
the most famous canadian in the world
was overwhelmed by
his the archetypal force of his
representation as the good guy it's a
great documentary hitman heart
and and it shows you how you know pro
wrestling is is it's not the world's
most intellectual activity to say the
least and people can easily be
dismissive of it but one of the things i
loved about the documentary was that it
attempted to
understand from within what was
compelling about what was being
portrayed and it was a religious drama
it just was shocking and brilliant
and so
so that is that is actually there is a
there's an objective
part of that that there's an objective
way in which these patterns kind of come
together and manifest let's say higher
and higher versions of this drama
uh and so the sports drama has a certain
level but it's it's limited to a certain
extent because it still
happens as a confrontation let's say
between two irreducible sides and so
what happens in something like the story
of christ is that
that gets taken into one person and so
all the opposites
become
the king and the the the the criminal
the you know the highest even in the
image of the cross you have this image
sandy as christ is being crucified they
are putting a sign above his head saying
that he's the king as christ is being
beaten they're giving to him a crown and
so
christ
joins together all the opposites and so
in his in his
story you see if you if you're attentive
to these patterns you see the highest
form of this pattern being played out
and one of the aspects that has to be
there for it to be the most revealed or
highest form is that it also has to
include the world of manifestation
i mean it can't just be a story it has
to be connected to the world so that's
why christians insist on the the the
fact that jesus is not just a story that
he's an incarnated man that he was
incarnated but i don't believe their
insistence
i don't believe well this is this is
because
i don't it isn't obvious to me and i
think
maybe i derived this criticism from
nietzsche
but
you know people have asked me whether or
not i believe in god and
i've answered in various ways
no but i'm afraid he probably exists
that's that's one answer
um yeah no but i'm terrified he might
exist that that would be truthful answer
to some degree or that i act as if god
exists
which i think is
i'd do my best to do that but then
there's a real stumbling block there
because
there's no limit to what would happen if
you acted like god existed
yeah you know what i mean because
i believe that
that acting that
out fully
i mean
maybe it's not reasonable to say to
believers you aren't sufficiently
transformed for me to believe that you
believe in god
or that you believe the story that
you're telling me you're not you're not
as sufficient you're not the way you
live is a sufficient testament to the
truth and people would certainly say
that let's say about the catholic church
or at least the way that it's been
portrayed is that with all the sexual
corruption for example it's like really
really you believe that the son of god
that jesus christ was the son of god and
yet you act that way and i'm supposed to
buy your belief
and it seems to me that the church is
actually quite um
guilty on that account because
the attempts to clean up the mess have
been rather half-hearted in my
estimation
and so i don't think people
people don't manif
christians don't manifest this and i'm
including myself i suppose in that
description
perhaps um
don't manifest
the
transformation of attitude that would
enable that enables the outside observer
to
easily conclude that they believe yeah
now the way the way to deal with that or
the way to to understand that is that
it
they do but they do in a hierarchy
there's a there's a hierarchy of
manifestation of the transformation that
god offers the world and we kind of live
in that hierarchy and those above us
hold us together you would say and so in
the church there's a testimony of the
saints there's there are stories there
are hundreds and hundreds of stories of
people who live that out in their
particular context
to the limit of what it's possible to
live it and even today there are
there are saints living saints who for
example like in the orthodox tradition
we have this idea of what they call it
the gift of tears or the joyful sorrow
of of
people who live in prayer a with weeping
constant weeping
uh and it's this kind of strange mix of
joy and uh and sadness which they which
kind of overwhelm them and they live in
that joy and sadness non-stop and they
pray you know without end and so that
exists but then we
in this that's one of the reasons why
that's kind of one of the reasons why
when i talk about this idea of attention
like it manifests itself in the in the
church as well is that
you often say
and i understand it when you say
something like you know i act as if god
exists or you know i'm afraid to say
that god exists uh and i think it's
because you you think or you tend to
think that the moral weight
like of that is so strong that you would
we would crumble under it that you would
just be crushed under it and
and i believe that
and i think that that's i think that i i
understand that but
the first thing that to act as if god
exists let's say it this way to act as
as if god exists the first thing that it
asks of you is not
a moral action
the first thing that it asks
asks of you is attention
that's why to act as if god exists is
first of all to worship
like that's and it's i know people are
going to hear this well then i have then
i have a terrible problem with that too
at the moment because i'm in so much
pain like one of the things that one of
these theologians
discussed the idea of and sorry i want
to let you get back to your point but he
discussed the idea of the yoke of christ
being light and that there is joy in it
and
um
and there's a paradox there obviously
because it's it's also a take up your
cross and follow me sort of thing but
um
the fact that i've been living in
constant pain makes the idea of joy
seem
um cruel i would say
and so and i have no idea how to
reconcile myself to that i mean i've
reconciled myself to that by staying
alive despite it
you know um
although
by staying alive despite it but there's
very little worship and it doesn't mean
i'm not
appreciative of what i have i'm i'm not
only am i appreciative of what i have i
do everything i can to remind myself of
it all the time and so does my wife i
mean she's changed quite a bit as a
consequence of her
struggle with cancer you know has become
much more overtly religious i would say
and you know we
say grace before our meal in the evening
and it's very serious enterprise and it
always centers around gratitude you know
for
well for
for the ridiculous
volume of blessings that have been
showered down upon us
at a volume that's really quite
incomprehensible
but
despite that
well let
despite that i'm struggling with this
because i don't know how to reconcile
myself to the
to the fact of constant pain
yeah
and i don't i feel that it's unjust
which is halfway to being resentful
which is not a good outcome
no i i i agree and i can't speak like i
can't i don't know how to speak to that
because i don't necessarily don't have
that experience you know i don't i i
i don't have that i don't live with
constant pain and so i don't know what
that would do to me
probably probably one of the reasons why
it might ruin me you know and so
um
it's very difficult to answer that i
think that the answer like the answer
has been the cross like that's been the
answer it's maybe it may be easy for me
to just say it that way
but that's always been the answer of
of christianity which is that
that god went to to the cross and that
god went down into death and and plunged
down into death and there
that there are mysteries hidden
and there maybe they're very well hidden
but there are mysteries hidden in that
than that depth um
but uh it's not i don't think it's my
job to uh
to
to moralize to you at this point at this
particular moment
so we talked about the narrative and the
objective touching and so i wanted to
touch on that again is that like i
i i understand cs lewis's argument and
you know i'm even inclined
from time to time to think well i've got
the choice between believing two
impossible things
i can either believe that
in the world is constituted so that god
took on flesh and was crucified and and
and died and rose three days later or i
can believe that
human beings invented this unbelievably
preposterous story that stretched into
every
atom of of
culture
and
it isn't obvious to me that the second
hypothesis is any easier to believe than
the first because the more you
investigate
the the manifestations of the story of
christ the more insanely complicated and
far-reaching it becomes so i read ion
for example and for all of those who are
listening if you want to read a book
that will completely
make you insane
then you could read jung's eye on
and it's a study of christian symbolism
in astrology which doesn't sound
particularly dangerous but or or or
or even particularly necessary to read i
suppose but
jung describes the the juxtaposition of
astrological and christian symbolism and
it's a brilliant book and it's
terrifying because he he he outlines the
concordance between the levels of
symbolism over several thousand years
and it's obvious when you read the book
that no one plotted this it's not a
conspiracy whatever is going on to make
that concordance occur isn't something
that we understand and it seems to be
best
understood as one of these situations
where the narrative and the objective
touch the saturation of christianity
with fish symbolism jung associates with
astrological movement of
of uh
into the house of pisces
and and so he he describes how a
drama so ancient people saw a drama
played out in the sky and that was a
projection of their imagination
and that projection contained symbols
that were associated with the emergence
of christianity and so you you can see
in that the the the alternative
explanation is that there's this
there's this unfolding of a symbolic
landscape over centuries or millennia
that's part of human biological and
cultural evolution
but that that starts to
touch on the religious anyways when you
when you describe it in those terms
like it's it's it's the operation of a
of a cognitive of a natural cognitive
process let's say natural slash
cognitive process that supersedes any
one individual or any one culture
and so
i've never seen a critique of ion you
know i think people read that book and
they think
it's like john allegro's uh the sacred
the mushroom and the sacred cross do you
know of that book i believe that's the
title that's another book you read and
you think well i have no idea what it
it's a study of
mushroom symbolism in christianity and
it's another book that you know it
claims that
christianity was heavily influenced
by psilocybin use and it was published
in the 1960s it's an amazing book but
it's another book you read and you think
i have no idea what to do with that i
have no place to put that book
so
but ion is really like that and
well one of the things that for example
you know we talked about just before the
idea that
um you know
the idea of christ being a dying and
resurrecting god and you know
that's really actually not the case if
you actually just look at the story of
christ and not just the story in
scripture but let's say the whole story
as it kind of developed in tradition it
kind of melded together in the ancient
world you had this idea of gods that
went down into the underworld you know
either that went down for some reason to
visit or went down to save somebody even
or you know or or or died and then and
then rose again but that's actually not
the story of christ because if you if
you understand the full tradition of the
christian story we think that christ
died
went into hades
and then destroyed death
and he pulls everybody out of death and
then that's it like what other story are
you going to tell after that story
you have a story
of someone who dies goes into death and
then
take and then destroys death and then
that's it like that that's the thing
with christ's story that every story
every aspect of his story reaches the
limit of storytelling
and it's it's impossible
beyond it right that's right that's
right well even from a psychological
perspective that's correct
and that in itself is a kind of miracle
and so you're stuck in some sense
constantly having to choose between
miracles it's like okay
it's a it's a figment of the human
imagination fine but it's the limit
figment in multiple ways how did that
happen
and also but as soon as you start to
start to think that the world is made of
attention the idea of just a figment of
somebody's imagination especially
just a figment of someone's imagination
which is happens like you said over
thousands of years within communities of
thousands of people it just becomes a
ridiculous statement it doesn't it
doesn't mean anything it's like yeah it
only means something if you assume that
and jung pointed this out it only means
something it only
to say it's a figment of imagination
and have that brush it aside means that
you think that imagination is nothing
and you pointed out constantly that you
should not attribute nothing to the
psyche
it's what you depend upon it's it's the
ground of your existence it's it's it's
it's not nothing it's the thing you that
you take for granted more than anything
else
so any anything that you can
recognize as a story will definitely be
manifesting patterns that you can
recognize and so they can't just be
brushed aside from this from the most
insane conspiracy theory
to the the most you know like childish
fairy tale anything that manifests
itself as a as a pattern of story that
you can recognize
is has a certain level of value has a
this
enough level that if you pay attention
to it you actually can
gather some some some nuggets of uh of
how the world works and how the world
lays itself out uh you know and that's
why like if i do symbolic
interpretations i can do it for
scripture but i can also do it for some
marvel movie or some video game or
whatever it is because that's just the
for you to even recognize something as
having being it's already part of that
world it's already manifesting these
patterns
now and that is one of the things that
that narrative does is that it enables
us to
play out ideas that we're not yet
intelligent enough to understand and
sometimes
the gap between the narrative
representation and the explicit
understanding can be thousands and
thousands of years because we're still
unwrapping well we're certainly still
unwrapping the bible we're unwrapping
we're still unwrapping shakespeare
there's more depth there than we can
than we can understand explicitly
and so anything that uses character has
that tremendous advantage and then it
also there's also this strange ability
that some people have in spades
to
create fictional worlds that are of
unbelievable profundity and power and
i mean the greatest example of that in
the last 30 years in terms of sheer
imaginative power has got to be jk
rowling and the harry potter series
which you know grip the imagination of
the entire planet
for for a decade and produced untold
wealth and spread literacy everywhere as
well
she had an un
a remarkably creative imagination and
something quite mysterious
and so you're you're fortunate enough to
work at the marriage of ideas and and
and drama
yes and and you know it's it's really
interesting when when you've spoken
about dostoevsky and and others uh
in some of your lectures i i'm
fascinated
by him and all the russians i studied
russian for four years in college and
and read some of these in the original
my russian wasn't
fluent enough for me to really i mean i
had to grind through them but
tolstoy
chekhov chekhov who was a doctor a
medical doctor as well as a writer
so that
that
congruence of
of a commitment not just in terms of
literature but it did he used
his profession
as a doctor
to also inform him um
as a writer he famously said
[Music]
medicine is my
is my wife and literature is my mistress
and when i tire of one i spend time with
the other
um and
um
i and pushkin um who would
who would write stories that that were
full of thought
but the story itself
was bigger than any thought he could put
around it it was it was more resonant it
it carried more um
by the way
when i listened to your your biblical
series
it caused me to decide to read through
the whole bible
and
just start to finish and i grew up
southern baptist so
ever since i could read
i've read the bible
virtually every day of my life but i'd
never read the bible start to finish and
there were some books that even when i
was a religion major at university
i would get to some of the books and go
i i can't stay awake for this book i
just got to move on
but when you really go through it
and you see the
the old testament
as
this
this incredible saga of a people trying
to find the rules
that that kept them together as a people
and it felt
if you disobey these rules
then it's going to end badly for us all
and
the greatest
the greatest violation is to erect
altars to other gods right let's worship
false idols yeah that's the worst one
and then along comes jesus who is
completely steeped
in all that old testament i mean he is
he is profound in his knowledge of it
and he lives and does
and says these things but it's not like
it's a philosophy it's a narrative a
narrative which
i've studied a great deal and i believe
is
is largely historical or i should say
significantly historical
i believe these things did happen and
then you have saint paul
who's trying to make sense
of what happened
and and and it's mind-blowing to me
it's mind-blowing to to read it as a
whole and put it into perspective in
that having having spent my life in
what's mind-blowing about it in in part
i mean and i try to speak of the bible
not from the perspective of a committed
believer and i have my reasons for that
um
i guess it's partly because i want to
concentrate on
what everyone can come to see as true i
suppose perhaps that's it
um
but
it is remarkable
that the bible does in fact make a
coherent narrative
because we don't understand that it was
seek it was written by a very diverse
range of people over a span of time that
we can perhaps not even imagine it's
very difficult to tell how old this the
oldest stories in genesis particular are
the
the the story of the fall and
of adam and eve and and cain and abel
they bear all the hallmarks of a
previous oral tradition
that would have existed
in relatively unchanged form for tens of
thousands of years and perhaps even
longer than that and so they're
unbelievably ancient and then
parts of it obviously are newer and
the written parts are obviously newer
than any tentative oral tradition but
you have a
you have at the bare minimum an
unbelievably deep psychological document
that weaves itself
over centuries into a coherent story and
northrop frye i would say he's a
canadian literary
critic has did more for me than any
other
particular thinker
to help me understand the nature of the
narrative because fr fry i suppose he
did the same thing
or i'm doing the same thing that he did
because he preceded me also at the
university of toronto
he assessed the bible as a work of
literature
as a narrative
and
that to me was never any denigration
because
narrative
a powerful narrative and you talk about
this when you talk about braveheart for
example because
there isn't that much known about
william wallace historically but you
craft you crafted a narrative that's
that was true enough let's say
to be unbelievably attractive to people
and to motivate them very deeply because
it's an affecting movie well and if it
wasn't it wouldn't have been so popular
um
and so there's a there's a truth in
narrative that i think is even deeper
than historical truth a true like a
truly profound narrative truth is like
the average of a whole variety of
historical truths and so it's the
essence of historical truth
so it's even more true than his than
than what we would consider say
eyewitness history because eyewitness
history is just
it's one battle you know and and there's
maybe an epic theme in that battle but
then imagine that you could look at a
thousand battles and you could and you
could extract out from that what was
canonical about heroic victory across
all 1000 battles you see something like
that happening in the old testament and
the narrative the narrative thread is
really quite deep
their
societies emerge
formulate
fall off the path
worship false idols collapse
and then the same thing happens again
and the collapse happens and the
collapse happens because people
become too prideful the kings in
particular they don't listen to the
voice of conscience they and a prophetic
voice arises and says you're wandering
off the
tried and true path and you're going to
be punished terribly for that and
generally speaking the kings ignore that
and
catastrophe breaks free
and you see
and in the old testament in particular
there's the promise of
the ultimate state in some sense there's
utopian promises that run through it the
search for the promised land and then so
strangely you see that transformed into
something that's not really political in
the new testament you see that the
promised land becomes the nature of
experience as a consequence of a
particular form of moral being
and and then perhaps that has political
implications because people who acted
like that would produce a particular
state but it's no longer
it's it's it's no longer the dream of
establishing the state that will
solve all problems it's psychologized
and it's it's unbelievably profound
and it it's and that's i think you can
derive all of that from from the
biblical writings
without
even starting to move on to classically
religious territory and
and it's and then that does beg the
question of course is what does all that
wisdom point to in the final analysis
and that's when the questions start to
become religious
yes
and it will jordan it that's that's the
part to me that um
it takes it into a whole whole different
realm as you as you say
um
there's a quote from mary oliver that a
friend shared with me recently it's uh
keep some room in your heart for the
unimaginable
and i find that
in in a great story in any or any great
piece of art
that surprise is the central currency of
its power
there's an element of if you will of
revelation
if you will and
i i think it was paul tillich i'm not
sure who said that
religion is
man's way to god and is always erroneous
but revelation is god's way to man maybe
it's carl bart
it's god's way to man and it's always
perfect well there's there's a
revelatory aspect to any great story
when you're telling someone a story
and they didn't see coming what just
happened
that's what makes them
awake that's what stabs them broad awake
you know what my the most powerful
takeaway for me was from my biblical
series which which is what
the meaning of the word israel
wrestling with god we who wrestle with
god we who struggle with god yeah it's
like well maybe that's the real
christian spirit is
and that's what that phrase implies and
that's the real jewish spirit
yeah wrestling john
why does what you know why does why is
there that strange scene of the
wrestling with the angel like why would
you possibly fight with god and then you
think well god isn't that what i'm doing
all the
time partially doing all the time he
partially wins though that's what's even
more mysterious and hurts you doing so
yeah i mean that's that's that's the
story but isn't that the story
i mean it isn't belief it's the
wrestling with belief and and
and it's wrestling in the way that
you're wrestling
well i mean i do sparring and i often
use sparring as um a metaphor uh for the
kind oh so that's the other metaphor for
dialogue yeah exactly it's not just the
tracking it's the sparring yeah and and
we have to remember
yeah you know and that kind of sums up
men's relationships well well played
with each other tracking and sparring
plato means big shoulders he was a
wrestler
that's his nickname his nickname is
plato because he's a wrestler and we
have to remember that the greeks are in
the gymnasium even more than there are
in the academy right i was watching this
suits episode last night and
the
the are always sparring with each other
verbally you know and they're tracking
something they're tracking victory in
this series they're they're finally uh
and they wrestle they wrestle when they
fight they they have to go into a clinch
in a fight to settle their disputes like
a physical fight but there's
you can shift off of that this happened
bernardo and i when we were doing this
uh we both said this you can shift off
of it and this happens when you're
actually martial arts sparring because
you get into the shared flow state you
can shift off of victory to the
aesthetics of the dance
there's a beauty in that that is an
independent vic that's independent of
victory that you can come to appreciate
for its own sake plato talks about this
he talks about this the beauty the eros
that draws you into the that's why
yeah a dance but it but it's a dance
that draws you beyond yourself
education right to draw forth from you
and so is that the is that the battle
with the adversary
is that related to the this is another
very serious question obviously
it's a question related to the book of
job
i don't know because i i see parallels
you know in nietzsche's quote you know i
hate socrates he's so close to me i'm
always fighting him right you can see
you can see
both nietzsche and kirkegaard wrestling
with socrates kirkegaard said
i follow jesus but socrates is my
teacher and he wrestles with socrates
all the way through everybody's
wrestling with soccer i follow jesus but
socrates is my teacher so is that the
statement of the west
um
i think that i mean that was your
objection at the beginning of this talk
right
at least to some degree because you said
how influenced you were with greece you
insisted on how influenced you were by
greece
i think the west is
the
attempt to
if i had to try and summarize the west
what an audacious thing to try and do
see rock rock said that because i asked
him why dionysius transformed into
christ because we were answering simple
questions too and he said well greece
met
judaism
yeah but judaism also meant
greece i mean violence starts theology
because of the interaction
uh with with platonic philosophy i i
think you uh christianity is trying to
integrate agape and logos together
that's how i try to understand this
project and when
please clarify that claim sure so i
think i mean we've talked a lot about
the greek heritage of logos and logos is
also central uh
within
especially in the book of john yeah
especially in the book of john um
and saying that metaphorically with
regard to you as well
but also in the epistle of john is where
john also said god is agape
right and then that's the epistle of
john he makes that famous statement and
and and the idea is there's something
there's something about the way the
logos gathers things together so they
belong together that's the original okay
so that everything comes together
everything comes together and then
there's the idea
of the ascent from the cave the anagogi
you and jonathan talked about this the
world discloses itself to me that
transforms me and then i can see more
deeply into the world then that
transforms me and i do this reciprocal
opening and the thing is that's very
much if you you know you know and agape
that's do you define that that's love
yeah
accelerating mutual disclosure is how
it's even disco well it seemed to me
well it seemed to me that that the
relationship between truth and love is
that love is the is the something like
the goal and truth is it's servant it's
it seems to me to be say because i
so this is how i've worked it on my in
my mind is that sure well i think that
truth is the best servant of reality
truth is the servant of reality and
reality
i think
best manifests itself is love
well one of the slogans i have
that's why this power of claim is so
abhorrent to me the claim that power is
the central motivating factor for the
western endeavor is tandamount i believe
to saying that it's the basic endeavor
of the human species and i think that's
opposite of the truth i think this agape
is
and logos is more accurate and so it's
not just a counter claim it's an
antithesis
well i'm trying to pick up on what
you're saying here i mean
you know i'm trying to touch on the
culture wars obviously
well that's
yeah i i i mean i think um i mean
for me you're saying something very
analogous to a critique that i've built
in the awakening for the meeting crisis
let's hear it man well [ __ ] shut up
no it's
okay that i mean like i was going to say
one of my signatures is you know the
it's in latin but it translates as love
is its own way of knowing and the kind
of knowing there is is like noticing
like news
that's the egyptian eye
well yes it's noticing it's not thinking
it's attention
and maybe you're tying that with that
revelation of the form you're tying that
to that revelation of the form and that
conforming
yeah and that's exactly it that's
exactly it it's it's it's and this is
very similar to the buddhist idea of
that the
the what you're trying to do is shape
attention in mindfulness so that you get
that reciprocal opening so that your
your self-knowledge and the knowledge of
the of the world are become uh
indistinguishable become
interpenetrating like what you have when
you really love somebody in a committed
long-term relationship your knowing of
yourself and your knowing of them become
bound up because you indwell them and
you internalize them and they indwell
you and internalize you right and and
how much how much death of the old you
has this involved for you
i know that's a strange question no it's
a good question it's a damn good
question why
it's a good question because
it brings up the idea of the fact that
there's a level of knowing that deals
with the process of identification
itself in both senses of the word
identifying designating something and
assuming an identity
in both those senses of identification
the kind of knowing that i most care
about this participatory knowing
involves identification and therefore if
we're talking about the transformation
at that level we're talking about like
that's what i mean about when i talk
about knowing
knowing yourself i don't mean
representing yourself i mean the knowing
that constitutes you as a self and
that's what's undergoing the
transformation when you're engaged in
participatory knowing when i really love
my partner
right i'm not just forming what does it
mean that you love them do you think if
you have to express that how would you
express that well
i mean it means a lot it means that
reciprocal opening i was talking about
but it means that i i mean
it's like what eckhart says and again i
don't mean to be pretentious like you
you know he said you have to make a
space i don't think you're going to be
able to help it in this conversation
yeah that's true that's fair enough he
says you know you have to god forgive us
the goal of rhineland mysticism was to
this kind of receptivity you have to
make a space so that the son of god can
be born within you and and again no not
being disrespected you know irreligious
but
for me to to to love my partner is to
cultivate that kind of receptivity a
space in which
she can be within me and i don't mean in
any room
purely romantic metaphorical sense what
i mean is she finds a purchase within me
whereby she can realize herself in both
senses of the word realize and and she
can come to trust that that space that
place of realization will always be
available for her and she can come to
rely on it a place through which she can
transcend herself when she needs to i
mean and and being and being committed
to that and finding that inseparably
bound up with my own project of trying
to realize who i am that's for me
the core of what it is to love somebody
that's great
i wish you luck with it
well that's all we can ever wish anybody
i mean if you're if you're in the grace
of god
or or yeah
or or that there is a life to this
relationship
that will eventually grow strong enough
that we can come to trust in it as much
as we trust in each other and that's
what i believe is happening for me
um
and
i think
there's kind of three loves involved and
they're all bound up together there's
you know socratic self-love not
narcissistic self-love there's the the
love of the other and then there's the
love of the relationship but but but
talk that for me is like a trinity
talking about if those who are separate
is the mistake you have to talk about it
analytically as if they're separate but
they interpenetrate and inter-afford
each other in a profound way they become
they become in an important sense
indistinguishable from each other think
about this admiration is the instinct to
emulate
okay so then we look for the most
emulatable
that's the ultimate spirit
and and i think gerard is right that
that always carries with it the dark
side of mimetic envy and covetousness
and that those two are always playing
off against each other well because
because we think we can possess it by by
by
ill-got means yeah that's the story of
cain yes yes and of course that's
carried with us because the story of
human history is the battle between abel
and kane which is also why i asked you
about this fundamental cultural crisis
that's
tearing us apart
and you said well that's a manifestation
of deeper things and that's well that's
what i asked too yeah and that's and i
and i i hope that what we've been doing
is actually my answer to to that um ah i
can say more about because i've been
i've been involved and i'm involved in
some actual experiments on awe and the
effects on cognition uh and some of the
work i don't know if what we've been
doing is the answer to that or the
antidote to that to which sorry well if
the question is posed wrong we can't
really answer it can we we have to
provide an alternative formulation but
that's what i think we're doing here
yeah so it's an antidote rather than an
answer
and that's fine
i know i know i'm just clarifying it i'm
i i think i i think looking for the
answer
is in some sense a fundamental way of
mis-framing it that is to that is to
give into the problem well how do we
address it then how do we
address it do we just buy step it and
just offer the alternative no no think
about this
that's a genuine question because
perhaps we do just by sidestep it and
offer the alternative yes that's what
i'm saying that's what i that's sorry i
want to be more responsible that's what
i'm recommending that's what i'm
recommending see one of the things i've
thought is that at minimum what
christianity is is a
thousands of years long discussion about
what constitutes the human ideal
it's a purely psychological viewpoint
now i i understand the metaphysical
implications you know that and i don't
want to dispense with them but it's best
to start with what's simple
so there's this discussion of of
of what constitutes the ideal and we're
we're we're exploring it and discussing
it and and we explore and discuss it in
all sorts of interesting ways right
because it's not merely rational we bach
writes this
soul-inspiring music and that makes us
feel a particular way and that's a hint
as to the nature of the ideal and then
there's these great cathedrals that are
built all across europe and they're
awe-inspiring masterpieces of stone and
light right so opposites conjoined and
they bring the primeval forest into the
city and they provide color and the
music is set in there and then there's
the invocation of the ancestors and and
and the and that and the dogmatic
formulations that that christianity
consists of that go back centuries as
well and and all of that and that's all
part of this exploration and to me it's
the exploration of that central
animating spirit and when we're debating
the post-modernists who say everything
is power
this is the sort of thing that needs to
be pointed out as a rejoinder it's like
no it's not we're doing our best to
manifest this ideal that we're
discussing we're flawed and fragmented
and ignorant and we don't know so for
example you asked me earlier nigel
what sort of things i had to discuss in
order to make people attracted say to a
discussion of genesis and what it is is
that i i try to get the wheat from the
text and
and in the chaff i think a lot of that's
my ignorance it's not necessarily chaff
but i'll leave it be because i can't i
don't have the intellectual wherewithal
to make sense of it so i just leave it
be without despising it because i can't
understand it doesn't mean there isn't
something to it now
you know we're still stuck because we
have problems like well the idea of the
resurrection you know which
is obviously
a very big problem in in in a very
fundamental sense and i leave that be
except to say that i i have seen you
know in my studies of mythology that
there are stories of dying and
resurrecting gods throughout history and
the idea of christ seems to be
of that type although it's not only that
but it's something i can't touch and
that's a problem but that doesn't mean
that
there isn't this investigation that
we're all undertaking including us in
this conversation of what constitutes
the ideal and how we could manifest it
if we could only understand it
and i think that's unbelievably
compelling to people and it's it's it's
not only compelling they die without it
it
because we can't live with only
knowledge of our limitations
we have to be moving towards an ideal
well i mean just to just a quick quick
thought there i mean
certainly within the christian tradition
the claim is that
uh
god's decision to become incarnate is
not accidental he chose this particular
human being not just because he had to
choose some human being in order to
become a human being
but he chose a human being and as it
were exhibited the qualities that he
wanted to as it were
disseminate as a kind of moral exemplar
that were profoundly cult
counter-cultural to the values and the
the exemplars of the time
um so you you think of the kind of uh
the the the weakness of christ in some
contexts the sort of the
obviously the sense of self-sacrifice
the radical openness to
those on the margins the poor in
particular uh the the uh ceremonially
unclean and of course to to to women and
so it's as if that this is completely
subverting the kind of the sort of power
narrative that dominated
uh for first century palestine
particularly in the form of the
um the the sort of the roman legions and
and the roman uh imperium and so so i i
think that's um that's a quick thought
i've really been struck constantly by
some of jung's descriptions of christ as
a member of the trinity because
cr jung makes much of
john's sense of christ the logos that's
there across time which i read something
as something like create the creative
consciousness that's involved in the
bringing to awareness of being something
like that so it's maybe identical to
consciousness itself at least in its
higher
stages it's very abstract but then
there's christ the carpenter who lived
in a particular time and place which is
kind of a mystery because everyone asks
like in the movie jesus christ superstar
you know uh
why that time in that place and the
answer is well it has to be some bounded
time and place and so if we're
if if what christ is is a representative
in some sense of what a human being is
is that there's a divine
aspect to us which is this creative
consciousness that's very abstract but
it's also localized intensely you know
in a historic in an arbitrary throne to
use the existential phrase historical
context and then
each of us is unique in that manner but
there's something universal about each
of us too that enables us to reach out
to each other and
and also gives each of our individual
lives
a larger significance that otherwise
they just wouldn't have at all well yes
and the significance you know one of my
students once asked me a brilliant
question is like well if the if all
stories have the archetypal structure
why not just tell the same archetype
over and over
and i thought you know wasn't that so
interesting because what you want is you
want
old wine and new skins so to speak right
you want you want the universal story
particularized
and then i thought well that's exactly
what jung said about the figure of
christ is it's the universe the story
particularized and and both of those
like both the particularization and the
universality it's the intersection of
those two that produces the meaning
and it also produces
i guess you say meaning i would say
human dignity
because on the one hand there is
individuality
no one
quite grasps the truth or speaks the
truth in my time and place
like me
so
in a sense everyone is a unique prophet
and has a unique responsibility but
we are commonly subject to
a universal order
universal obligations universal calling
which which
endows our little lives with a larger
significance
the important things are hard to
articulate in words they're implicit
meanings all the deep things like love
religion
poetry music how do you say these in
words how do you say them in language
but they have extraordinary meaning and
power they're the things we live for not
for the things that we can say
put down in a notebook if you know what
i mean
i i try to look at things
scientifically in so far as the science
allows those things to be viewed okay
and so to the degree that i can look at
religious matters from a biological
perspective i do that because it's
simpler okay so i believe that the
religious instinct manifests itself in a
variety of fundamental uh uh motivations
but they're they're they're abstract
motivations to some degree so
the experience of law
that's a major one the the
experience of beauty
that's another one
the
the experience of admiration
and the desire to imitate
those are those are crucial
and so
so one of the things that i would point
out you can tell me what you think about
this and i've been trying to formalize
this idea and i don't know its extent
so
i look at christianity in particular
although not uniquely christianity but
christianity in particular as
a thousands of years uh investigation
into the structure of the abstracted
ideal to imitate
so imagine
we imitate those we admire
okay but we're abstract creatures so we
want to know what's the essence of what
should be imitated itself now we
investigate that it's not all explicit
we have to represent it in music we have
to represent it in art we have to
represent it in architecture because
we're we're we're hitting at it from
multiple different domains and that is a
reductionistic argument right it says
nothing to do about divinity itself sure
it's purely it's purely psychological or
a biological argument you're saying that
everything's relevant
that what these philosophers were
talking about what
these artists were painting
what these musicians are doing what
filmmakers are doing
this is all
something
that is trying to get us that way no
that's what the cathedral represents
you know it's it's it's it's an
expression in stone of this yearning to
to bring the material world into harmony
with the spirit it's something like that
and that's what music does as well
and there's this this proclivity within
us to strive upward
and the cathedral i mean the cathedrals
they're absolutely amazing these
lattice-like
structures of stone there's something
about the harmonious interplay of shadow
and light that's key to it as well it's
it's like the opening up of dark matter
to the light that pours in that's all
embodied in the architecture and
and and i i i can't say and neither can
anyone else what that ultimately
represents and then to bring music into
that space
and and tradition
it's all pointing upward to something to
to the direction that we're supposed to
go it's it's so terrible to see these
buildings empty out i mean thank god
that they're being preserved in some
sense by the tourists who come there
driven by a sense of awe
but we've we can't inhabit them anymore
the way that we used to and that's a
that's a terrible thing it means there's
a kind of ideal that we that we're no
longer
we're no longer pursuing
perhaps we're no longer pursuing it it
seems like a catastrophe to me
no one really knows how to revitalize it
though unfortunately
so
well the i think one of the problems to
me when when i was in paris working on
men in the iron mask
i would want on a sunday morning to to
go to a mass
and it was very difficult to find
[Music]
well for one thing in a baptist we would
church would start at 11 o'clock on a
sunday morning and the masses aren't
like that
but
go into say the cathedral
saint-germain
and
there was no one there it was a it's
magnificent ancient cathedral and
and
you know a few tourists and
the place
the place didn't feel dead the
architecture was alive but but it it was
very difficult to have a congregation
and a congregation is
what the church of course
is supposed to be
it's it's
a collection of people
who are united and and
indifferent it's you know it's a
collection of sinners
um
acknowledging their sins
and i i think that
that is a fascinating thing to me about
how we keep
um
well it's so surprising it's also so
surprising that
those hundreds of years ago when those
buildings most of those buildings were
built that
those cultures would dedicate themselves
to such great cost to produce these
absolutely spectacular impossible
buildings made out of stone or brick
these these these
they're like a dance in stone
they're so magnificent and then to fill
them with with
the greatest of artworks and and to to
to bring the light in in the most
colorful possible ways and then to bring
the music in to set the scene and then
to have everyone come in and commit
to
at least not being as bad as they were
right like it was a joint moral
enterprise that everyone was involved in
you can be as cynical about that as you
want and and talk about you know sunday
christians and all of that but an hour a
week to contemplate
how it is that you should be living your
life or to become
in tune with your conscience once again
which at least the confession can offer
that
um
and and and then to see that so much
effort was poured into that
it's amazing that that over occurred and
and then it's also equally amazing that
we've stopped doing it because you might
think well
wouldn't
wouldn't we be interested in
jointly coming together and saying well
here's how we're inadequate and
here's how we're conceptualizing what
would be ideal and
couldn't we move together
toward that
and
i was talking to bishop baron this week
and about this issue about
the the loss especially in the catholic
church of young people and
it seems that there's a great adventure
there
that isn't being
communicated properly
and and
and it's a terrible loss
for all of us what do we have to replace
that
you know i've talked to the new atheists
especially sam harris
and it's not like i don't understand
their arguments it's not like i don't
have sympathy for them for that matter
but
there's nothing poetic or artistic or
magnificent
about
the alternative
yes right it loses it loses it loses
there's something that just disappears
it's the it's that artistic ineffability
there's no room there's no obvious room
for that in the
say the enlightenment world view i i'm
an admirer of
stephen pinker for example
um and he falls into the enlightenment
rationalist camp
um
and in his book the language instinct he
talks a little bit at the end about
culture philosophy music art and all of
that religion even for that matter to
some degree but it's like a throwaway
chapter at the end whereas by my way of
looking that's the whole book
all of that that artistic endeavor and
that shades into the religious endeavor
and that that's the scent that's not
some side effect of human cognitive
development quite the contrary it's the
central feature
and i agree
with jordan when when you're speaking
with julia um the the most recent uh
podcast i heard um the uh it reminded me
her her description of her life reminded
me of an experience i had in russia
i was in saint petersburg and we were
doing a scout
for a film i wrote called love and honor
based on a novel that i wrote and
and we were
finished with the scout we had seen
everything that
that we were scheduled to see
and this young woman who was in her
early 30s a russian woman
asked if there was anything else we'd
like to see
because we had some time and i said well
i'd love to see some of your churches
and she got this quizzical look on her
face she was surprised that i don't know
a hollywood director would ask that
and she said well i'll take you to my
church
and i said
you've got a church
and she said oh yes i'm christian and i
said but
you grew up when that was
discouraged even almost illegal
are your parents christian and she said
no
mother's a
confirmed atheist or her father was
baptized as a child but he's also an
atheist and so i said well how did you
become christian
and she said
there was no beauty
i was a young girl walking around and
nothing was beautiful
and one day i passed the church and i
could see candlelight in it and heard
music coming out
and i went in and i kept going and i
kept going and i became a christian
and in
and that to me
says so much
um and people have no idea they have no
idea that's why i wrote chapter eight
they have no idea how much they're
starving for beauty yes like it's it's a
hunger that goes far beyond
well let's not say that it doesn't have
to go beyond material hunger but
it it
no matter how well fed you are without
some relationship to beauty there's too
much suffering in the world for it to be
viable it's the ant it's along with
truth it's the antidote to
to suffering
it's not opt it's not uh optional
right it's crucial and you can tell that
by its economic value for those who are
hard-headed it's like you can't point to
anything with more economic value
period the end
and so
well some weeks back when you were you
were
i felt
really working your way back that that
that work and engagement and
in your calling um
is
helping to heal and sustain you
you said something along the lines of
that
that you wondered why
in the
christian community and religious
community people
were telling you that
um
your work means so much you know why
why it it it's
it's somewhat overwhelming
to realize that
so many people are drawing from you and
and i think i can do this completely it
is i i today i was sitting on a bench
with my friend who walks with me
and this kid came up to me
and he said
apologies for interrupting you but i was
listening to your podcast while i was
walking down the street and i saw you
here he said
and he started to tear up right away he
said five years ago i was suicidal
and i was i've been listening to your
lectures on a regular basis he said an
hour and a half a day which
seems like an overdose to me
um
he said
he's invented prosthetic limbs and has
helped all sorts of disabled people and
is on his way to mit
it's like
just a random
meeting on the street you know
yes
yes
and thank god for that too much
yes of course it is
but i tell you and like i know you like
to understand you know that's the the
um there's something else you said a
couple weeks back about
i i want to
i want to understand why i want to
understand why this story makes sense
and and i do too
but the what of it all
um that to me gets at the why of it all
but the what of it all
is that
you
speak to people like me
and like others who
who know this
this experience of more
who know
who know what it is to stand in awe
to
to feel the awe of a moment
and you combine
all the different elements of
of perspective of thought of experience
and you
you
validate or endorse that
that people who choose faith
and who seek courage and sacrifice
as
crucial
divine values
are not idiots
it's i think that that's and it's no
accident that crucial and cross are the
same thing yes
yes
exactly
and and and you know we we go through
this thing of well um
you're just you're you're choosing an
opiate
and and to me it's like well
um
the the alternative is not attractive
too i when i started working on the pope
story i came across a
a statement that i believe is
one of the
talk show
guys late night talk show guys had said
conan o'brien i believe it was but he
said that
pope francis had made a pronouncement
that he thought even atheists could go
to heaven
and in gratitude atheists have said um
that the pope when he dies is welcome to
enter their endless void of nothingness
so well that you know the problem with
that world view is in some sense that
endless void of nothingness confronts us
right here and now
yes exactly that i i try to tell people
i'm i'm not so much concerned about life
after death is life after birth
jesus said
come that you can have life and have it
more abundantly
and and i'm not trying in a movie to
to
espouse my particular dog i don't
believe in my own dogma my you know my
own dogma is
is is limited and
and i'm not i'm not trying to think that
when i was in school and i'd study
systematic theologians and i remember
asking my mentor who was the head of the
department
um
what is really the point what
what are they trying to do and you said
well they're they're trying to
have a system
of
understanding that that holds up
um
from every angle
but well how's that working out for them
because ultimately
you get into
do you have faith or not when i write a
story it's
it's
i've got to jump in and trust
and i don't know where they'll lead
but i know that to not
jump in is
is death
and
so for me it's like
the old testament says you know i set
before you life and death
choose life
and and that to me is
what i i hope my work's about
and i'm damn sure it's what your work's
about
let's delve into this faith issue a bit
too
because the faith is a very complicated
term and
you know it's often
parodied
but by the rationalists you know
to have faith in god
is
parodied as a
like a
primitive and superstitious
belief
but
my psychological investigations
convinced me that there's no action
without faith
because we are always stepping into the
unknown
we have to take a leap of faith to
exist
to do the simplest of things to
literally to move and that has to do
with what i said earlier is that
we're trying to move from a place of
less value to a place of more value
so we have to make some assumptions
about what constitutes value
and then we have to believe that our
actions are going to have the outcome
that we desire
and we do that without evidence i mean
that's partly why to be human is to be
riven with anxiety it's because there's
no certainty and so
you can't act without faith and so then
the question might if you accept that
proposition you can't act without faith
and i actually believe i don't believe
that that's a
disputable proposition unless you view
people as deterministic in the way that
clocks are
you know so that we're just stimulus
response machines it seems to me that
instead we're moving into the unknown
and we do that
in dread in some sense dread and hope
and we do that because we have faith and
when we lose that faith our lives fall
apart
and and we don't know which way is up or
down and so then the question is well if
we have to have faith
what is it that we should have faith in
and then the answer seems to be
something like well we should have
if we have to make a decision about that
maybe we try to have faith in what in in
the idea that the best should be pursued
and will prevail
as an organizing principle and then the
question is well what is the best and
the answer is well that's really hard
question and so we need cathedrals and
we need box music and we need the
stories in genesis and we need the
world's great literature and we need all
of that
theater and drama and art and aesthetics
to help us understand what the best is
and to determine how it should prevail
and i don't see that technically as any
different from
i think it is the same thing
psychologically
as the worship of christ
i think it's the same thing
because again i'm trying to speak
psychologically to think about what
christ represents i'm not thinking about
him as a historical figure that's
something we can get to later
that image
which is seen for example
laid out on these massive cathedral
domes
christ as logos as as generator of the
world it's
it's the idea that the proper mode of
being is brought into existence by
consciousness that's operating according
to the highest possible principles
and like
why wouldn't
and that is the kind of faith that's
maybe got some courage associated with
it right i'm going to act as if this is
the case we're all going to act as if
this is the case
now that begs the question does that
make it real well
pope benedict xvi was a great
intellectual hero of mine said the
church always does three essential
things
the church worships god
it evangelizes and it cares for the poor
poor broadly construed as i say anyone
who's suffering right but that first
move as we said earlier is indispensable
the church worships god it teaches the
world right praise because without right
praise the whole thing falls apart
secondly it evangelizes what's that well
that's a cool thing too because
uwangelian in greek good news
they were playing with that because the
the romans would have used that in the
eastern part of the empire
to announce an imperial victory they
would send an evangelist ahead with the
good news ewan guelion hey caesar won a
victory so these very edgy first
christians who had zero social status no
power no military behind them said oh no
no i got the true eu on galion it's
about jesus risen from the dead who was
put to death by caesar but whom god
raised so that's the proclamation of the
good news that now we have hope now the
sacrifice has been made and god's love
is greater than anything that's in the
world okay now i got those two things in
place
now serve the poor now go where the pain
is go where the suffering is but if you
divorce them from each other and that
that has happened so who cares about
worship and that's fussing around with
altars and sacristies and who cares
about evangelization let's just get down
and serve the poor then it does devolve
simply into social work right but if the
three are together worship god
evangelize the dying and rising of jesus
and serve the poor now the church is is
cooking you know all right so let's
let's look at the second one of those so
yeah you know it seems to me i i can
understand this not that whether i can
understand it or not is a hallmark of
its validity but i have to try to
understand what i can understand
i can understand the idea that bearing
forward in a moral direction acting as
if
being is intrinsically good and that hum
that humanity as part of that is also
intrinsically good
bearing up under
bearing all that up as a set of
propositions even in the most extreme
cases of suffering i can see that as a
valid moral good
that's that's christ's refusal to be
um
what would you say corrupted by the
injustice of his and and terror of his
fate
and so that might be something like
you don't have the right to become a
tyrant no matter how badly you were
tyrannized let's say
yeah and i think that's an unshakable
moral proposition
but then there's the resurrection
element of it because i could say well
the first thing i would say is well i
kind of understand that psychologically
parts of us die and
and they have to die because they're in
error they have to be cast off and
we're reborn constantly as a consequence
of our movement our ascent forward
there's no movement forward without some
death of the past
and so i can see the resurrection idea
as a
metaphor for the part of us that
continues onward despite our failures
and constantly reconstitutes our spirit
it's not something trivial
but then there's the insistence on in
the church of the bodily resurrection
which is well
let's call that a stumbling block to
modern belief no no doubt about that
that's something more than mere metaphor
and so you might ask well why is it
insisted upon why isn't the proposition
that
you you have a transcendent moral
obligation to bear
to to to operate for the good of all
things regardless of your suffering
a hard line
no justification with
the defeat of death necessitated
i'm not trying to make a fundamental
critique of the idea of the resurrection
because i know there are things that i
don't know i i know that for sure
and god only knows how the world is
fundamentally structured but
but it seems and this is a nietzschean
criticism in some sense tuna freudian
criticism it's
that seems in in some real sense too
good to be true
yeah so
and and so what do you make of the what
do you make of the resurrection how do
you conceptualize it even as it's
related in the gospels
yeah good you're raising a lot of
interesting things first of all
everything you said about it in terms of
psychological um archetypes and
metaphors good fine i think those are
legitimate i think those are our correct
perceptions of things and it has indeed
functioned that way in a lot of the
literature of the world resurrection
type stories
but i think what's really interesting
about the new testament
as as lewis said you know c.s lewis when
someone said well
the new testament is just another
iteration of the ancient myth and he
said anyone that says that has not read
many myths because there's something so
distinctive about the new testament and
what i i would say jordan first this
i think from the first page of matthew
through revelation
what you get throughout is this what i
call this grab you by the shoulders
quality
they knew about literature that is
conveying deep psychological and and
philosophical truth you know paul
certainly knew that literature very well
um
it doesn't sound like that though
it has overtones with it it bears some
of that it has family resemblances with
it
but what what you find on every page
is this
one galleon this good news so everything
you said is true i think it is true
but it's not exactly news it's part of
the philosophy of parents that's been
around for a long time and a lot of the
great thinkers of the world and again i
agree with it i like the philosophy
apprentice
but the new testament is people
who grabbed everyone they met by the
shoulders to say
something happened something's happened
here that we were not expecting that was
not part of our of our thought system
and it's so shaken us up
that we feel obligated to go careering
around the world and indeed to our
deaths
announcing it and defending it and what
it was was the
here
fact
the in the 10th chapter of acts of the
apostles uh
this sort of almost tossed offline
we who ate and drank with him
after his resurrection from the dead
um
i don't think people trading in mythic
talk
use that kind of language mythic
language again i say it with high praise
i love the myths
uh but you know once upon a time and in
a galaxy far far away and then a mythic
story unfolds
but you read the ask the apostles uh do
you hear about what happened first is up
in galilee and then in judea you know
those people that john the bap remember
john the baptist well and then there's
jesus and then in jerusalem and then
we who ate and drank with him after his
resurrection from the dead
it's that's what and then look at paul
paul who saw him on the road to damascus
now the paul line letters man they do
not read like myths they just don't and
i love the myths i love the philosophy
apprentice but it doesn't read like that
it reads like someone who is has been so
bowled over by something and he wants
you to know about it and it's changed
everything
and i think what it was was what we said
earlier it's
okay now now we know
god's mercy
and love is greater than anything we can
possibly do why because we killed god
and that's why paul will say i'm gonna
hold up one thing to you christ and him
crucified and crucified i mean it was
the most horrific thing they could
imagine in the ancient world it was
deeply embarrassing even to talk about a
crucifixion paul says no no let me put
it right in your face see
the author of life came and we killed
him but i got the good news who won
gilean
is god's mercy and love is is
greater because he brought this jesus
back from the dead
well you do have a you do have
the following argument which is that
it isn't clear which is harder to
believe whether that happened or whether
people made it up
because if they made it up that was
really something and that that does
strike me quite frequently reading the
new testament there are lines in there
that hit so hard you think
hmm it isn't obvious to me how someone
could have just thought that up
so and there is that well and jung carl
jung
who i greatly admire you know he
believed i think in the same way that
c.s lewis did that and he doesn't talk
about this that much
but that there is this archetypal
mythological pattern of the dying and
resurrecting hero that has this
psychological reality which is
extraordinarily deep yeah but that that
archetype was realized once in history
and that's the fully realized so it it
came from the
mythic realm let's say the realm of
eternal truth the realm of pattern
instinctive pattern for that matter and
was fully realized at one point in
history and you might think well if it's
going to be fully realized it has to
start somewhere
you know it it can't start everywhere at
the same time or right
right what does an archetype look like
when it takes flesh
might be a way to get out well well and
the thing is we we do see this and it
does grip us because
movies like we see representations of
this all the time
in
in my new book i talk a fair bit about
harry potter
and you know harry potter is definitely
an archetype take crazy figures taken
flesh well clearly he's in battle with
satan himself obviously i mean and and
she has an unbelievably profound
mythological imagination and the thing
that's so fascinating about all of that
is that because her
mythological imagination is spot on she
captivated the entire globe and and
produced you know this immense
storehouse of wealth and dominated the
entertainment landscape for a decade and
you know people don't take that
seriously but it's a it's a great
mystery to watch that
absolutely they should it's it's a it's
a phenom you know anything that grips
people's attention like that is
obviously worth paying attention to by
so you know emer lewis called them good
dreams right so all the sort of
archetypal anticipations of the gospel
the good dreams of the race um or do you
think jungian i love young too
but what happens if that archetype of
the person perfectly pleasing to god you
know kant's language
what would happen if that archetype
became flesh and indeed that's how they
put it the word became flesh and dwelt
among us i think that's also the
question we should each be asking
ourselves
in our own lives yeah it's like well who
could we be
and you say well you don't have to ask
yourself that question it's like well
good luck with your conscience then
you should be another christ that's the
objection to the self-created person
it's like
yeah
the the idea that you can create your
own values is well good luck right try
good luck with that project yeah good
luck it's not it's not going to work
you know newman referred to the
conscience i always love this as the
aboriginal vicar of christ in the soul
so he took the language descriptive of
the pope you know the vicar of christ
but he said the aboriginal vicar of
christ which is the conscience john
henry newman okay because oh i was
thinking of eric neumann so no john
henry newman and i it's it's a beautiful
way of describing it because we'd say
the christ dwelling within you
is the voice of the conscience that's
calling you to
sanctity ultimately to heroic
self-sacrifice to being who christ is it
also is it is what people worship
because
here's a way of thinking about it
technically well
look when i have a conversation with you
there's something i want from you
i want i want everything you can give me
i want you to be as
as as as there as you can possibly be
that's what i've been demanding all the
time if my attention
assuming a
properly constituted subjectivity if my
attention wanders
that means you're not delivering and so
if you're wandering around and
everyone's attention is wandering away
from you you're not delivering and
conscience
because we're so social we're social
creatures to the final degree conscience
tells you when you deviate from the
ideal and that ideal is what people
worship they by attending to that
manifestation of the ideal in you
they worship it
and so that's their
it's there in the
in the demands that we can't help but
make of each other and of ourselves
there's no escape from that
and so i i do think it's a perfectly
good question
what would happen
and this is the right question for your
life what would happen if you took that
seriously and so again what i see is
that it doesn't seem to me to be
if the church can no longer attract
young people it has to be
that they're not taking that with
sufficient seriousness
now yeah i i think there's a lot to that
i don't want to externalize the blame
it's like i know the church is a human
organization and all of that and but but
it's still evident but it's not just you
know it's it's not just about going to
church i one time i i told you something
and
and i don't know if i could drive if i
was able to drive it through there
there's something about being in a
hierarchy
that is that
because there's an aspect of being in a
hierarchy that you talk about which is
this kind of striving
to to kind of be the best within that
hierarchy but there's an aspect of being
in a hierarchy which is that the
hierarchy covers you oh definitely
there's no doubt about that yeah and so
there's something about that's why the
lowest member the lowest status members
of a chimp group will still fight off
interlopers yeah and so there's there's
a value in being in a community and a
and a hierarchy where you
like i go to confession right i i go to
confession i go to my priest and i
confess my sins and and i give that to
him
he actually takes responsibility
for for an aspect of listening to my
sins
and and kind of participating in my
salvation and he and so the weight ends
up being distributed across the
community
it's not so you don't actually just bear
it on your on yourself and it's not just
even and it's not just a living
community it's a it's not just those
that are alive in the in the hierarchy
but those that are that have left their
story all the saints are part of this
hierarchy that you
engage in that you participate in and
that you see as consolation as examples
as you know as
examples of people who have lived
through difficult things that you can
kind of
uh that you can shoulder up against you
know and so that's one of the reasons
why i i kind of insist with at least for
the people that watch my videos is
is
when i say go to church it's not just
because i
try to moralize you into doing something
it's because it's a it's actually a
participation in how the best vision of
reality works
i've got no objection to any of that
but i've seen you i've seen you
objection i'm probably one of the only
people in the world that has actually
seen you in church and seen
you yeah that's worm and squirm in
church
why
see the other thing
i was reading again i was reading this
book and it's mostly a jumping off place
for me to think it's like
there's also something
because i'm not inside the church so to
speak it's hard to say what the utility
of that is
the utility of being inside the church
of being outside it oh being said
because i'm an outsider talking about
religious matters yeah but i think that
i think that
i think that it has played a great role
like i i've often said something that
i've often said that you're something
like king cyrus if you know the story of
king cyrus in scripture king cyrus was a
persian king
who told the jews to go back to israel
and build their temple so he wasn't
jewish like he was he wasn't an
israelite he wouldn't believe in the god
of the israelites but he was like hey
you know that temple of yours looks
pretty nice why don't you just go back
there and and rebuild your own own thing
and so that's definitely an effect that
i've seen you have you know the number
of people that have become christian
because of you is hilarious sorry it's
not hilarious but it's just kind of it's
just kind of this strange thing because
you you you kind of stand outside and
you look at you're looking at the door
and you're looking at the church and
you're saying hey this isn't not so bad
you know look at this what is what is
going on here like what is this about
and and then because of that oh it's
also do you think you've got something
better
what was it milton
wasn't didn't milton write paradise laws
to justify the way of god
the ways of god to man
it's a hell of an ambition in some sense
that's what this entire religious
endeavor does the literary endeavor as
well
what's the point of all this what's the
meaning of this and
you know when you think about that in
two
two propositionally
and this i also saw this in my therapy
practice it's like well what's the
meaning of life and i could easily get
off on a nihilistic argument with some
of my more intelligent clients they had
a rejoinder for every proposition about
why life was valuable
but then if you said to them
don't be so sure that that part of you
is your friend look what it's doing to
you it's so destructive and it has all
of its self-justifying arguments and
they might even be coherent but look at
the consequences and then
contrast that
with
your own experience like when does that
sense of nihilistic despair disappear
you know for some people it's when
they're with people they love they're
with friends or family some people find
it in creative activity some people find
it in charity
there are various sources of meaning
and that's not propositional
you see it in your own life right you
can literally in therapy you have people
track that it's like well you're
nihilistically depressed let's let's
watch your life for a week and see how
that ebbs and flows with what you're
doing
and then see if we can get
you participating more in what makes it
ebb than what makes it flow and that's
empirical in a sense right i'm not
asking you to believe something i'm
asking you to watch the structure of
your own reality to see where meaning
manifests itself and then you could say
in some sense the sum total of
where meaning manifests itself that's
where god resides
and that relationship with god that you
described
as
as the
what would you say
as
that that has to be maintained by our
good behavior
i suppose that's that
desire
to live in that space of meaning
and
then you can propositionalize that you
can say well that's associated with love
and it's associated with courage it's
associated with these classical virtues
and it's not these things that we've
learned to deem as evil
and that's
that's where you is that is it
reasonable to say that that's where you
find god if you're searching is that the
is that an appropriate way of looking at
it
i think so i i met a guy one time who
told me he went to a lecture
and the lecture was on god's existence
and the guy who was lecturing and then
after the lecture my friend came up to
him and said
you know everything you say is a bunch
of malarkey there's no god it's just
your lecture is just meaningless
and the guy said okay
what i want you to do is for the next
week i want you to treat everyone
that you meet
as if they were jesus in disguise
and the guy left the lecture and he went
home and you know he gets home and you
know mom's there doing the dishes and he
thought to himself well if this were
jesus and disguise doing the dishes i'd
probably go up and like help my mom do
the dishes
and then dad came home from work and
rather than ignore me said hey dad how
was how was work how's everything going
and you know because if that were really
jesus in disguise i would do that and
then they're eating dinner together with
the family and there's one hamburger
left and he turns to his brother says
hey why don't you have this
and the guy told me his life was
completely transformed by literally one
week
of acting in this sort of way
and that's not really surprising pope
benedict talked about this in one of his
encyclicals that one way to god
is to act in this sort of way to act as
if god exists right right to act as if
other people are jesus in disguise and
you know mother teresa talked about that
too that in for her
the poor and the leper and the destitute
were all jesus
in disguise and so she served them as if
they were jesus
and so that is one way
it seems to me to move towards god i
don't think it's the only way though and
the reason is that
i know a philosopher alastair mcintyre
who mentioned to us in class one day
that he was an atheist until he
carefully studied the arguments for
god's existence so there are at least
some people at least one person alastair
mcintyre who really did come to god
through that way but i think the more
common way is through
lived practice lived action yeah you you
brought up the the case of of severe
depression and um
you know
it is the case of course that
you can make
profoundly coherent arguments of for why
your life is meaningless and why
meaning there is just a vast nullity to
all existence but the question isn't are
they coherent the question is are they
true the question is are the premises
right because anything can be coherent
within false premises the questions are
is it the case that your life is worth
nothing and the answer has to be no
that's a false statement it's a false
apprehension of
reality oh look what happens if you act
that out
of course but even then you could say
well no i'd be doing a sum if within
within the grips of depression you'd
still be thinking that i am acting
according to a good given the premises
that i have about the meaninglessness of
my own life and of all life
so i think the foundation it keeps going
back to the same question the foundation
of truth must be there but then the next
thing to say is not that you are wrong
about your life being meaningless as a
false statement but that you're also
loved
you are loved
and it's i think that's the kind of
thing at least my own experience
that can take you out of the darkness
that your life is not about you and your
own thoughts it's not about you and the
systems that you are building
ultimately you are in response to
something much greater than you and that
thing that's greater than you is looking
at you and calling you out and saying i
love you so it's not it's not an either
or it's not well what's true
propositionally about the nature of
existence and is there a soul it's it is
that and
i'm calling you
which is a universal call for us as
catholics
this
exercise that you described dr kaiser
i believe that
when we see other people
except under
very extraordinary circumstances we see
an illusion that we project upon them
mostly it's a simplifying illusion we
don't see the whole person partly i
suppose because we we couldn't tolerate
the
the complete vision
it would be too much for us you know so
our doors of perception are three
quarters closed and exactly why that is
isn't obvious but
i do believe that the more accurately
you perceive a person
the more you perceive them in the manner
that you described
you see this eternal
recurring
conscious
hero
striving against the darkness
it's
and when you treat people like that
of course they're
what compelled by that
it's a compelling way to be interacted
with
although i don't know what it is is that
maybe
it's not obvious how much of that you
can tolerate which is a very strange
thing too
you know
i'm thinking about this
most of what we perceive is our memory
and sometimes that
is stripped away and we see what's there
but seeing what's there is awes aw
inspiring
it's it's it's gripping and and it
instills terror and i think that's the
same as the burning bush
and in some sense everything is a
burning bush
but
you're blinded to it
the
you you see what's there
i think when you really love someone a
child
you really see that in a child if you if
you're a parent
right
you see
you don't see a generic baby you see
that actual person
so that memory that
pushes generic baby into your field of
vision dissipates and you see what's
actually there and that love drives that
i imagine it does that
it love seems to
like i always saw when people fall in
love with one another they see the
perfection that could conceivably exist
it's like the curtains of of illusion
pull apart momentarily and you see the
paradisal state that could be there
hypothetically if everything was done
properly
and that drives the love
and then maybe if you work across time
you can achieve that to some degree
you know because other people think
about themselves as deluded when they're
in love and
that's a very cynical way of looking at
it
it certainly doesn't apply
to the love between a parent and a child
yeah i think i think you're right i mean
i know in my own life um having children
has been such a unbelievably enriching
experience and i think about
um you know especially when kids are
little and they're asleep you go in
there and they're just sleeping and you
see their little chest moving up and
down
there's something painfully beautiful
about that i mean you just wish it could
go on
just indefinitely and
for me that is something that taught me
something about about god's love right
if god really is
god the father
well then you know we that's sort of how
he looks at us and he sees the good
he sees the effort and of course there's
imperfections too but i don't know it
for me
having children is a kind of
i try to sometimes tell my students
most of whom don't have kids what it's
like and it's very hard to describe so
the best way i came up with was well
remember when you were a little child
you're like six
and you thought um
oh boys have cooties girls have cooties
and the idea of romance or kissing
someone is just repulsive and then you
know you could imagine trying to explain
to a six-year-old look at some point
you're going to look at someone else and
just find this person unbelievably
captivating and you're going to want to
kiss them and you can say the words but
a little kid's been like
no way that that's hard to describe and
and i think becoming a parent is similar
to that in that
yeah it seems to me
that it is so
enriching
that
and has given so much at least to my
life and including calling out something
for me that would have never been
elicited because there's kind of
sacrifices that you'll do for a kid that
you'll never do for you know an adult
so that that's interesting
that ties in with this this idea that
you brought forward of treating
everybody as if they were manifestation
of christ
you see that
meaningful fragility in your children
and it's beautiful
and
maybe if you're
if you've been warped and hurt you get
resentful about it
and jealous of it and that can lead to
all sorts of terrible things but to the
degree that you can that you're
privileged to see that
that calls you to be a better person
and you can think of that you know
biologically well
you have these fragile creatures
that you're responsible for
of course that's going to call you to a
higher mode of
action because otherwise they're not
going to live you know so it's it's very
practical but
so then but what you see there is if
that if you
view someone with love
then it's incumbent upon you
to treat them as if they're valuable
and then the more you treat other people
as if they're valuable
the better person you are that just
comes along for the ride in some sense
so none of that seems questionable to me
that that seems solid
and so then maybe the more the more love
you view other people with
the higher the moral demand that's
placed on you and then i would say too
well then
that's another reason why
it's so important to be truthful and and
in some sense to be good because it
isn't obvious to me that you can
withstand that moral load
if you're
compromised by
too much sin
it's too much
and then that's another thing that that
we're not very good at teaching young
people about you know we shouldn't do
that you know it's like
there's a
sanctimonious authority that goes along
with that that's the wrong tone it's
more like
you know
i don't know how you lay it out properly
but you tell people that you love
how to avoid the road to hell
and you don't do that because you're
shaking your finger at them or because
you're
a moral authority
you do it because you don't want them to
burn
and i think there's too much of the
moral authority still in the church and
not enough of the
you know the love that
helps people avoid
the fire
i assume
i think what you just beautifully
described is the the unity of the love
commandment that you you love your you
love god with all your heart and all
your soul and all your mind and you love
your neighbor as yourself
the love the love of god identifies the
pattern and then they interplay between
the love of the neighbor and the love of
the self they're they're inextricable
they're differentiated but inextricably
intertwined
so to to love the neighbor is to see the
neighbor as he or she actually is and to
respond to the actuality not to your
desires not to what you want this person
to be in a utilitarian or instrumental
sense but to the reality of that eternal
soul right there
and in and through that then you see who
you are
that's a commentary on the ten
commandments right that's christ's
summation of the ten commandments so
that's another
another
illustration of that abstraction
proper behavior the story on top of that
the propositions that would be the ten
commandments let's say so then christ is
challenged on the ten commandments
something like
rank order these if you're so wise
right exactly because you're going to
say something heretical
and christ does this unbelievable
sleight of mind
and and extracts out two superordinate
principles
and it's done in such a compelling way
that the interlocutor who's basically a
prosecutorial mind
like an inquisitionist in some sense
is reduced to silence
that's that's a very powerful story it's
one of those stories you read that you
think
it's not obvious how someone could have
made that up
there's a lot of genius
there's an immense well of moral genius
in that story and
the idea that that's some sort of casual
false construct
you know produced
for the purposes of power
it's like well you try to write a story
that short that that's that is that wise
see how far you get with it
so
no i'm a catholic heck rituals our whole
thing you know
yeah well there's peace in ritual right
that's the thing you know what to expect
it's a place of safety and and and in a
world that changes constantly
ritual is the only thing that provides
order and so we may need that now more
than ever because things are changing so
unbelievably fast which is also partly
why the church should be careful about
being too relevant it's like i agree
i agree
catholicism is as sane as people get
you know it's baroque right and and
it's gothic not baroque it's gothic it's
dark it's it's it's it it has the same
aesthetic in some sense as a horror film
and i'm not being i'm not being i'm not
saying something denigrating by that i
mean it's part of its strange mystery
and all that strangeness is necessary
because people would be much more insane
without it than they are with it
it's a container for that religious
impulse and that impulse is to the to
the good
yeah and it and and the image of the of
the crucified christ
and also the act of communion gathers in
all the extremes together right it's
like if you think of the symbolism of
communion you'll notice that it gathers
in every extreme from the highest to the
most uh transgressive all of it comes
together it's worth unpacking that it's
ritual cannibalism in the service of god
yeah yeah but it's also it's also seen
as a
as a normal like meal of communion and
it's then also seen as
a as a sexual union because
you there's a relationship there's a
notion in which then in the altar and in
that moment of communion there's the
joining of heaven and earth you know
they raise up the chalice and there's
this joining which is which is this
image of this the sexual of union
between god and the soul between god and
his church and so all of it it just
jammed into this into into this ritual
as a kind of center of reality would
call it
um and so like you said if you get rid
of that then you're going to have all
kinds of strange factitious versions of
it that are going to pop up
and are going to try to replace it and
it's leading to the fragmentation of our
world and to the breakdown of the west
for sure